the day-to-day routine of Dr gears
consisted of a few constants piping hot
cups of black unsweetened coffee plain
dry wheat toast the soothing sounds of
his favorite white noise machine and the
endless Carousel of experiments with
scp-914 not that he was complaining he
was perfectly content to spend his time
supervising one of the few anomalies he
crossed paths with on a regular basis
that was unlikely to kill or maim him in
any way not that the Clockworks hadn't
produced its fair share of unpredictable
results over the years of extensive
testing it had definitely offered up
more than a few surprises and anyone who
knew Dr gears knew that he was not
especially fond of surprises Dr bright
had attempted to throw a surprise
birthday party for the man once but when
he turned on the lights and fired the
confetti cannon all Dr gears did in
response was give a deep sigh and say
really Jack you're making a spectacle of
yourself still he had resigned himself
long ago to the fact that supervising
the experiments with scp-914 meant
witnessing some truly unpredictable
outcomes how could he forget the time
researcher Blas tested an incandescent
light bulb on the setting very fine and
the Machine spat out an anthropomorphic
humanoid light bulb that spoke in German
accented English and claimed to be
Thomas Edison himself this was of course
impossible as historical records surely
would have indicated if Thomas Edison
was a walking talking light bulb rather
than a human man the Imposter was
eventually incinerated after its
presence became too irritating to ignore
and then there was the time researcher
Thompson filled out a Dungeons and
Dragons character sheet and placed it
into the machine on the setting very
fine the output produced was a sheet of
paper promoting the previously
non-existent tabletop role-playing game
fear in the foundation whenever a person
read the paper they would suddenly find
themselves in an out of Body Experience
where they were inside the game's world
which contains several characters
related to the SCP Foundation as well as
items and locations based on real-world
counterparts a subject in this state
would only snap back to reality after
winning or dying in the game researcher
Jacobson were all the one on stealth and
saw
scp-096's face in the game and was later
found dead in the anomalous item storage
Wing there was no shortage of foundation
staff trying to use the machine for
personal gain too Dr naysmith placed his
credit card inside on the setting very
fine using it to produce a card covered
in unidentified corporate insignias and
reading rank aleph infinite money
privileges when Dr Coltrane issued a
written warning Dr Naismith took that
warning and then placed it into the
machine on the same setting producing a
piece of official documentation from the
o5 council in support of his infinite
money privileges Junior researcher
Summers attempted to use scp-914 in a
misguided attempt at self-improvement
placing not an object but herself in the
intake Booth before running the machine
on the setting very fine it cleared her
skin lengthened her hair and improved
her figure this was of course in
violation of several employee guidelines
and she was promptly dismissed after
emerging from scp-914 Dr Veritas left a
note in the experiment log following
this incident reading by the time we
realized what she was actually doing it
was too late to stop her needless to say
she's since been terminated and I hope I
don't need to tell you all not to do
that again and with that the guideline
was clear no one was permitted to use
scp-914 for personal gain or to change
anything about themselves potential
complications were too risky not to
mention the conflicts of interest that
would be introduced into what should be
an impartial research process as
scientific objectivity's biggest fan Dr
gears couldn't agree more so as he
settled in for the day's round of tests
he intended to keep a watchful things
ensure that no funny business would take
place he didn't have much reason for
concern as his colleague Dr Bonita
prepped her research materials she was
working with two items a small replica
of Michelangelo's sculpture of David the
sealed envelope containing something
that was to be handled with Extreme
Caution a photograph of
scp-096's face she planned to place the
items inside on the very fine setting in
an attempt to see what result might be
produced from combining an ideal of
traditional beauty standards with the
image of a creature that felt such
profound shame and distress as its own
appearance that it would destroy anyone
who looked at its face like any good
scientist Dr Bonita wanted to remove any
unnecessary variables from her
experiment so as she placed her items
inside the intake Booth she slowly
delicately unsealed the envelope she
wanted to put the picture inside by
itself without the extra element of the
envelope potentially complicating things
unfortunately like Marie curie's slowly
unintentionally poisoning herself with
her own research materials she didn't
truly understand the danger of what she
held in her hands just as she was
setting the photograph down her eyes
flickered to the image before she could
stop herself before she could even look
away or squeeze her eyes shut she caught
a glimpse of the things she should never
scp-096's face she gasped and slammed
the photograph down but she knew it was
too late the sound of an inhuman shriek
coming from across the facility signaled
that she
would was coming for her and nothing in
the world could stop in a containment
cell on the other side of the facility
Foundation staff were horrified as they
heard The Telltale scream of an enraged
scp-096 the pale Finn creature once
huddled in the corner silently had
stretched to its full height of 2.38
meters and was screaming sobbing wailing
and gibberish and beginning to tear its
way out of its chamber guards tried
their best to subdue The Entity firing
their weapons at it but the bullets did
nothing to damage the creature's pale
flesh or stop its movements it ripped
through the steel Cube that contained it
and knocked the guards out of its way
with one
actually long arms sending them
careening into a nearby wall fortunately
for them scp-096 only knocked them
unconscious it didn't stop to harm them
further as it had a more important goal
in mind find the person who had seen its
face and Destroy them as the alarm
glared signifying a high Threat Level
containment range
scp-096 Lopes down the hall toward Dr
Bonita in s
Dr gears had not spotted Dr Bonita's
grave mistake and had no idea what had
triggered the alarm he was hearing he
stepped away from the observation window
turning his attention to the crisis that
was clearly happening somewhere else in
the facility meanwhile Dr Bonita was
panicking she saw her life flash before
her eyes the certainty of impending doom
that was coming for her and coming fast
all because of one brief error in
judgment what could she do there was
nowhere to hide no way she could run
away fast enough unless if she managed
to Allure 096 into the intake booth and
start the machine while the creature was
inside maybe it would transform into
something less intent on tearing her
limb from limb it was a risky move and
one that could jeopardize her position
at the foundation but she couldn't very
well keep her job if she was dead so it
seemed like it just might be worth a
shot a primal Roar Fury interrupted her
thoughts and she knew that SC
was moments away from breaking down the
door and getting its hands on her she
would have to move fast with a
screeching grind of metal on metal
scp-096 wrenched the door off its hinges
and barreled into the room in its search
for the person who had seen its face it
ran toward the silhouette of Dr Bonita
standing just at the entrance to the
intake Booth she tucked and rolled out
of the way just as the monster entered
the booth the door automatically slid
shut behind it at his scp-096 rattled
the door and tried to free itself she
turned the knob to very fine with every
ounce of strength and speed she had
there was a ding of a small Bell and the
Machine word to life as the objects
inside were refined Dr Bonita had no
idea what would be waiting for her in
the output Booth but she could only hope
that her last-ditch effort had managed
to save her life in the fog of panic she
briefly felt an itch of scientific
curiosity too what would become of a
being like scp-096 in a machine in a
strange and wonderful as scp-914 what
would the addition of the statue do to
it as a door to the outtake Booth slid
open Steam poured out it appeared her
questions would soon be answered
cautiously in spite of herself Dr Bonita
called out hello no one answered but she
heard the sound of footsteps slow and
careful as a figure emerged from the
Mist she covered her mouth and sharp her
eyes wide dear God she whispered in awe
standing in front of her with pale
smooth skin and the same imposing
stature was the most beautiful man she
had ever seen why dark eyes Shone under
thick sculpted eyebrows under the eyes
an aqualine nose full pouty lips a
strong sharp jawline his head was topped
with a tangle of lustrous dark curls it
was the kind of hair she had only seen
flowing in the Wind on the covers of the
romance novels she wanted desperately to
buy but was too embarrassed to be seen
purchasing his physique was well
statuesque like the build of the very
Michelangelo sculpture she had placed
into the machine just moments ago there
was no other way to say it he was
handsome despite still being a little
lanky and nine feet tall he peered at
her curiously towering over her in a way
that had been terrifying in his former
shape but now made her heart skip a beat
in an entirely different way I was
actually a good thing to say was she
blushing she shook her head snapping
herself out of it she was a scientist
damn it not some giddy school girl
passing notes in class this was an
incredible achievement something she
would need to study thoroughly and she
very much wanted to study him thoroughly
nope no time for that she needed to
write up a report to inform her
superiors to try her best not to lose
her job over this she had to remain
professional I the man that had once
been or perhaps still was as cp096 spoke
oh you you can talk Dr Bonita laughed in
Surprise the man's brow furrowed his
Newfound ability to speak was a surprise
to him too it seemed yes I can what
happened to me yeah stumbling over his
words slightly getting used to the
feeling of them you ran into the machine
she gestured to scp-914 I'm not exactly
sure to be honest but you're very
different now he nodded I feel different
I feel calm he sighed the relief plane
on his face before shadow of sadness
fell over him I don't think I have to
hurt anyone
I'm sorry for what I did before Dr
Bonita did not know what to say how do
you respond when something you've been
studying from afar been horrified and
fascinated by an equal measure looks at
you with a new beautiful face and
apologizes for all the harm it caused
this whole experience was so so surreal
she might think she was dreaming if she
didn't work at a place that was one long
waking dream or nightmare depending on
the day Dr Bonita there's been a
Containment Breach are you all right Dr
gears had returned to the room taking in
the sight of the destruction left in
096's way I'm fine she called to him and
he followed her voice into the room then
stopped at the site of the transformed
anomaly I don't have time for whatever
this is I trust you'll handle it Dr
gears took a long sip of his coffee and
taking Bonita's shock silence as
confirmation had a leisurely stroll back
to his office a few moments later the
guards responsible for containing
scp-096 arrived on the scene expecting
to see Carnage and find a docile scp-096
crouched over a lifeless body but
instead they found the same truly
bizarre site that Dr gears had Shrugged
off and Dr Bonita was still doing her
best to process they entered the room
with their weapons drawn but quickly
lowered them scratching their heads in
confusion instead before radioing their
superiors and asking for further
instructions responses from various
Foundation staff who caught a glimpse of
scp-096's bold noon look included oh
would you look at that who's that guy
he's what and in the words of Dr Jack
Bright oh no he's hot
Dr bright also proposed making the new
scp-096 a tick tock account and YouTube
channel seeking modeling representation
for him or selling a novelty calendar
filled with pictures of 096 in various
costumes these would be in his words
quote excellent ways to increase revenue
for the foundation so really you're the
weird ones now for thinking my ideas are
weird Dr Wright was asked to leave
scp-096 alone and stop trying to take
his headshot in the days that followed
the incident with scp-914 the SCP
Foundation was at a loss about what to
do with this new seemingly harmless
version of scp-096 dozens of d-class
were brought in to look at his face and
see if the entity would still enter one
of his range States after a few days of
getting used to his new form but he
never did no screaming no swallowing
people whole nothing more than a polite
is somewhat shy greeting and a courteous
how are you doing today the d-classes
were relieved but confused about being
pulled from their cells just to stare at
some random handsome man Dr clef
suggested dissecting scp-096 to see what
his new body looked like on the inside
this request was denied several
interviews were conducted to evaluate
scp-096's mental and emotional state now
that the anomaly was capable of coherent
speech it was much simpler to evaluate
the Potential Threat Level he might pose
every researcher who spoke with him came
to the same conclusion gone was the
danger of the old
scp-096 he had not just become beautiful
in a classical superficial sense but he
had become beautiful on the inside as
well interviewers reported a warm
friendly demeanor a talent for engaging
in conversation once he was made to feel
comfortable and a sincere interest in
the thoughts opinions and feelings of
those he spoke with there was only one
thing left to do to make sure that
scp-096 had really changed from
something deadly to something almost
resembling an ordinary person a
photograph of
scp-096's face of its original face was
removed from a Secure Vault by a d-class
then the d-class was sent into a room
with scp-096 and instructed to place the
photograph on the table
scp-096 looked down at what had once
been his face and his eyes felled with
tears a soft broken saw left his lips
and he wrapped his arms around himself
hunching over as if in physical pain
outside the room guards prepared to
handle things if 096 began to attack
instead he wiped his tears took a deep
shuddering breath and looked at the
d-class with a somber expression he
picked up the photograph on the table
and tore it in half as he finally
summoned the strength to speak please
get rid of these that is not who I am
anymore at Dr Bonita's strong insistence
backed up by the conclusions of the
research staff who interviewed scp-096 a
reevaluation of the entity's containment
measure was ordered it seemed cruel and
unnecessary waste of resources to keep
096 trapped in a steel cube in its
current form he would be moved to a
standard humanoid containment cell and
treated as well as other safe class
anomalies provided with books films food
and drink upon request and of course
other Comforts of course the o5 council
insisted on evaluating The Entity before
any of these changes could be approved
dressed in a specially tailored suit
provided by Dr Bonita
scp-096 appeared before the council to
present his case I know that I might not
have the best record at the foundation
I've done a lot of damage over the years
though let's be honest you all aren't
exactly innocent either sorry that was
an attempt of a joke I'm still very new
to talking all I can say is please
consider giving me another chance to
make a real life here to make this place
my home thank you for your time but
scp-096 didn't know is that the o5
council was so flabbergasted by the side
of his new face that they didn't retain
a single word he said they had all given
their official approval before he even
finished his short presentation before
long scp-096 was moved out of his steel
Cube and into a new containment chamber
that resembled the mid-range studio
apartment complete with a bed a
kitchenette a television and a table and
chairs it was provided access to all
major streaming platforms as well as a
large stack of books to help him develop
his grasp of culture and language after
so very long being isolated from Human
Society though he wasn't exactly human
he was determined to act like it word
quickly spread around the foundation's
site and humans and anomalies alike
flock to scp-096's new home to visit him
and see the miraculous transformation
for themselves
scp-999 was the first to come and see
the new and improved 096 chirping
excitedly as it oozed into his room he
pet the Slime gently his face breaking
into a warm Smile as its euphoric effect
wash over him this line became so
excited that meeting this new friend
someone it had known as a source of
sadness and hurt for so long that it
tackled him to the ground and tickled
him for several minutes 096 laughing
uproariously all the while
scp-343 stopped by to give 096 his
Blessing and wish him well in this new
chapter of Life a few days later
scp-507 popped back into the site and
wanted to see the changes for himself he
was thoroughly impressed though
privately confessed to missing 096's
more monstrous form which reminded him
of some of his favorite Cryptids there
was one anomaly that was not thrilled
with the appearance of scp-096 however
scp-056 was Furious upon hearing about
the new beautiful man that everyone just
couldn't shut up about it demanded a
chance to speak to scp-096 and to tell
him that this place isn't big enough for
the both of us I'm the fairest one of
all you sniveling little worm but the
request was denied
scp-056 talked about it for several
weeks meanwhile Dr Bonita was still
intent on getting to know
scp-096 better during previous testing
with scp-978 the desired camera a photo
taken of scp-096 revealed that his
greatest desire was to disappear curious
about the results would be now Dr Bonita
received permission to take another
picture of scp-096 she snapped the photo
while 096 was sitting in a chair in his
new containment chamber looking directly
at the camera when the photo developed
the result was simple everything in the
picture was exactly the same with one
exception Dr Bonito was pictured sitting
next 2096 her hand clasped in his both
were smiling soft contented smiles when
she showed him the photograph he smiled
at her and shook his head it really is
an amazing camera she flushed doctor
before you go could I ask her name Dr
Bonita smiled and nodded it's Isabelle
what should I call you SC 096 paused
thoughtfully for a moment he was giving
himself a name for the very first time
allowing himself an identity other than
a strange Hollow pale thing that existed
to cry and suffer and hurt finally he
answered her call me David down in the
depths of facility 23 a group of
scientists stand before a massive
rumbling piece of Machinery they all
hold their breath as the gigantic
mechanism suddenly stops it's eerily
quiet for a moment before a door slides
open the scientists crane their necks to
see inside to see what the result of
their great experiment was these were
some of the greatest Minds in the SCP
Foundation but nothing could prepare
them for what they had created September
9 2008 was an unseasonably Frosty day
when Dr Charles gears one of the SCP
foundation's most iconic scientists
parked his Honda Civic outside of what
seemed like an innocuous government Cold
Storage Warehouse he sipped his coffee
and surveyed the building which she
along with about a hundred others in
total knew to be site 19 facility 23.
why was Dr gears former director of all
Euclid level containment at site 19 here
today because official testing was about
to begin on
scp-914 the foundation had acquired the
machine now known as scp-914 some time
ago but only after its recent
reclassification to 914 had it been
relocated to facility 23. it must have
been important because the entirety of
the facility was being repurposed for
scp-914 research they were dealing with
an immensely complicated piece of
anomalous technology here and the same
question was on everybody's limbs what
exactly does this thing do Dr Arthur
Hackett the facility director had
requested the cold clinical assistance
of Dr gears in providing the answer once
he'd finish his morning coffee Dr gears
headed inside the facility security
chief agent Alan sedna had been beefing
up security of the building and at least
two mobile task force units were already
on call in case anything happened the
first day of official testing is always
a crap shoot you might get a nice drink
out of it like with scp-294 or you may
get an XK Class end of the world
scenario
you never really know all Dr gears knew
as he walked up the granite steps to the
main entrance was that he was already
feeling exhausted when you've dealt with
anomalous objects and entities for
decades on end the sense of wonder and
Mystery Begins to wear off only to be
replaced with a kind of tedium any
office worker knows all too well
everyone knew that Dr gears was devoted
to the job perhaps more than anyone else
but he approached the job with an
emotionless effect you wouldn't know
from looking at him if he was thinking
about the deadly anomalous creature in
the Next Room or what he was going to
have for lunch that day the doctor
passed through security and was briefed
in the break room by Dr Lucius Veritas
director of research at site 19. he
explained that the machine seemed to
work in the absence of any power source
its mechanical structure is similar to
Machinery from the Industrial Revolution
but it's exceedingly complex for
something constructed in that time
Foundation analyzes into the structure
of the 914 machine have shown it to have
as many as 8 million moving parts and
that might even be an incomplete
estimate Dr gears War's trademark blank
phase as he listened solemnly nodded and
asked to be shown the anomaly
he was led into containment chamber 109b
by a pair of guards according to all
current Foundation tests the machine
doesn't appear to pose any active risk
of containment breach or danger to the
guards earning it the rare safe
designation as a result aside from
guards stationed on site containment
procedures for 914 were minimal whether
this designation would need to be
changed after testing was something Dr
gears would soon find out
scp-914 was a truly impressive site to
Behold a giant Clockwork mechanism
taking up around 18 square feet with an
unfathomably complex combination of
screw drives belts pulleys Springs and
gears a less stoic researcher might see
the humor in recruiting a doctor gears
to test such a device but comedy
definitely wasn't one of Dr Gear's
Specialties he stared at the machine
with a detached Fascination analyzing
its vital components at a glance
gears noted a large mainspring beneath a
rudimentary selection panel the panel is
copper with a large selection knob fixed
to an arrow above a series of different
options rough coarse one-to-one fine and
very fine
there was also a large key below the
selection panel for the purposes of
winding up the mainspring and initiating
whatever procedure this machine was
designed to enact next Dr gears noticed
two large booths connected to the
Machine by a pair of equally large
copper tubes the booth on the left
labeled intake and the right labeled
output incredibly Dr gears was able to
immediately deduce the purpose of this
machine it was designed to enact some
kind of transformative process on
whatever was placed into the intake
Booth but what kind of transformative
process that's exactly what Dr gears was
here to find out the experiment was
simple they would gather a series of
samples both inanimate objects and
living tissue and use them to explore
the different permutations of the 914
machine's transformative abilities this
initial series of experiments were
approved by o5 command and the site
director and with the 47 researchers
present in facility 23 at his disposal
Dr gears commenced his research into
scp-914 to minimize risk Dr gears
decided the first test would be a simple
kilogram of Steel on his orders the
steel was placed into the intake Booth
with the doctor's approval a junior
researcher set the control panel setting
to rough and began twisting the main
spring key at which point the booth
stores closed and a small bell inside
Shine the machine began to rumble its 8
million working pieces churning into
life it continued like this for around
10 minutes before falling silent at
which point the output Booth opened what
had once been a single lump of Steel
weighing one kilogram was now an uneven
pile of smaller lumps with evidence of
laser cutting doctor gears May note of
the fact that having lasers within such
a machine is both anachronistic and
anomalous and that the rough setting
appears to messily cleave the object
placed within the intake Booth into
pieces Dr gears also noted that it would
be unwise to test any kind of explosive
material on the rough setting unless of
course they wanted to destroy the
building the research continued Dr gears
used another one kilogram lump of Steel
to test the one-to-one feature this time
the result was far more peculiar the
output Booth contained the exact same
weight in steel screws this result was
sparking even greater connections and Dr
Gear's impressive analytical mind
firstly the one-to-one feature caused
the 914 machine to transform the output
into something different from but
similar to the intake and while this
would require further testing it
appeared that the 914 machine despite
being anomalous does still follow the
laws of physics samples pass through the
machine conserve their mass and would
not be transmuted on an atomic level
from one element to another
next Dr gears pushed another lump of
Steel through the machine on the fine
setting the result this time was a
kilogram of Steel carpet tax from this
Dr gears was able to ascertain that the
fine feature improves the samples placed
within the intake booths somewhat
however things got even stranger when
gears performed the same experiment on
the very fine setting the output Booth
provided several unknown gases and a
lump of unknown metal with anomalous
qualities namely it was resistant to
heat up to 50 000 degrees impossible to
bend or break with any force and was a
perfect conductor of electricity
Dr gear suddenly realized his task here
may be more interesting than he'd
initially imagined was that a bit of a
smile on his face that one researcher
spotted surely not this was the famous
unflappable Dr gears after all the
doctor decided to take it up a notch and
began to test more complex items in the
914 machine he removed his own
wristwatch and placed it into the input
Booth before setting the machine to
coarse and letting her rip literally in
this case
when the output Booth was opened the
watch had been painstakingly
disassembled into its component parts
with no damage to said Parts Dr gears
noted the course feature as a more mild
version of the rough in the sense that
it was able to take an object apart
without any kind of fundamental damage
he also made note of the fact he'd need
to get himself a new watch Dr gears then
asked one of the researchers to
surrender their cell phone for testing
while none were excited at the prospect
of their phone getting eviscerated by A
Clockwork Behemoth one of the
researchers eventually surrendered their
Blackberry Curve to the doctor
he placed it into the intake booth on
the one-to-one setting and 10 minutes
later the output Booth released a brand
new Apple iPhone sadly for the
researcher who donated his BlackBerry he
wasn't allowed to keep the new device
naturally Dr gears was interested in
trying out the anomalous very fine
setting on a more complex object seeing
as no other researchers were eager to
hand over their personal effects he took
a cold python revolver from a member of
security and rammed that through the
machine on very fine
the result was an extremely powerful
energy weapon containing gamma radiation
which fired a beam capable of
disintegrating anything in its path
while the weapon's power was immense it
was also too dangerous and unstable to
be added to the foundation's Armory for
General use
having collected a wealth of data from
more complex objects Dr gears was eager
to move to the next stage live test
subjects
while his fellow researchers had some
reservations the experiments pushed on
beginning with mice a single white mouse
was put into the intake booth on the
one-to-one setting and the Machine was
activated
the result five minutes later was an
almost identical creature saved for the
fact that it now had brown fur
encouraged by the fact that the mouse
survived the refinery process Dr gears
next applied for the use of two chimps
in his scp-914 experiments
the first chimp was run through the
machine on the fine setting the result
was a chimp of human level intelligence
who has since begun working for the
foundation under the Alias Dr Bobo and
the data from this test has been
expunged from the official reports to
protect Dr Bobo's privacy the second
primate test this time on rough was not
quite as positive the chimp was
dismembered with the mutilated corpse
showing evidence of cutting from high
heat and crushing
of course everyone knew where these
tests were eventually going Dr gears
requested two members of d-class
personnel for testing the first was a 42
year old Caucasian male weighing 108
kilograms and standing 185 centimeters
tall Dr gears ran him through scp-914 on
the one-to-one setting resulting in a
slightly taller Hispanic man with a
slightly lower body weight
he immediately became severely confused
and agitated and attempted to attack the
guards present leading to his
unfortunate termination by Foundation
staff it was on the final live test that
tragedy truly struck a 28 year old
Caucasian male was run through the
machine on the highly anomalous very
fine setting the result was an utterly
nightmarish creature
so horrifying that the majority of the
details on its physical appearance have
been expunged from the Rapport the
creature made a sudden Escape reaching
the relatively minor containment
procedures intended for the inert
scp-914 this highly dangerous creature
killed eight guards as well as two
senior researchers upon emerging from
the output Booth a special response team
was dispatched to take the creature down
but that proved harder than expected
scp-914 had massively improved upon the
human original especially when it came
to its killing ability eventually it was
captured but the Special Response Team
suffered injuries and memory loss as a
result of the creature's anomalous
powers
the creature was also severely wounded
and its blood caused corrosive damage to
the plumbing in facility 23. the
creature expired from its injuries
several hours later turning into a cloud
of Blue Ash that blinded a nearby
research team Dr gears would later
comment that the experiments were
ultimately still a success in spite of
some minor hiccups testing on the device
continues to this day in an effort to
understand the full potential of the
machine though for obvious reasons
biological testing on the machine has
since been forbidden without direct
authorization from o5 command after all
if an already dangerous SCP was ever
subjected to the very fine
transformation setting we could be
dealing with something beyond our
greatest nightmares Dr gears was having
another boring day at the SCP Foundation
and that was exactly how he liked it he
treated himself to a cup of decaf black
coffee no cream no sugar a simple plain
donut and an apple The Breakfast of
Champions to him at least his duties
today were ones he'd overseen so many
times before watching his ever rotating
Legion of subordinates shove various
items into scp-914 the Clockworks just
to see what on Earth would happen this
machine had the ability to transmute
matter in a variety of Fashions
depending on the input selection whether
rough coarse one-to-one fine or even
very fine they tested everything from Dr
gears's watch to a chimp which as we all
know resulted in the Beloved
hyper-intelligent chimp scientist Dr
Bobo there were in fact such extensive
testing records for scp-914 that Dr
gears had started taking an
uncharacteristic hands-off approach to
testing as long as the researchers
working under him were reasonably sure
that the results of their testing
wouldn't result in a Containment Breach
a fundamental alteration of consensus
reality or some massive loss of life
they could just go ahead with whatever
dumb little experiment their heart
desired this however would turn out to
be a way longer leash than Dr gears ever
should have given to the kind of weirdos
who work at the SCP Foundation there had
been certain let's say incidents in the
past that have proved members of the SCP
Foundation aren't above using anomalies
inappropriately for their own personal
enjoyment there was of course the
incident with
scp-662 the butler's handbell and the
supernatural Butler it summons Mr Deeds
during the early stages of testing Dr
mirth under the guise of experimentation
made Mr Deeds make him tea wash his car
cut his hair and even do his laundry Dr
mirth was given a Stern talking to by
the o5 council for this abuse of power
good job o5 Council it's not like you
ever use anomalies for your own benefit
um let's move on nothing to see here
folks speaking of people working for the
foundation using a non inappropriately
who could forget the extremely
uncomfortable incident involving
scp-137 a real toy this anomaly has the
ability to become a real-life version of
any toy brought into its vicinity from
the Masters of the Universe to Barbie in
her dream house but one researcher was
hiding a horrifying secret he was a
brony and that's why he sneaked a
Twilight Sparkle toy into the testing
chamber so he could have a conversation
with his favorite My Little Pony
character which all in attendance agreed
just had incredibly rancid Vibes through
and through and that brings us back to
today Dr gears deciding to let his
subordinate researchers throw pretty
much anything into the Clockworks as
long as it was unlikely to cause
physical harm and leaving this
metaphorical door open allowed people
like Dr Siegel to step through you see
while Dr Siegel was considered by most
to be an incredibly diligent and
hard-working Junior researcher he did
have one Vice in his downtime he was a
card-carrying furry and we're not just
talking about a guy who watched Disney's
zootopia a few too many times he had his
own
fursona a wolf if you were curious I
personally wasn't he attended cons for
fellow furries semi-frequently and even
had his own expensive custom high-end
fursuit as such there was one SCP he
found particularly interesting
scp-1471 also known as Mao o version
1.0.0 an anomalous mobile app with some
extremely strange properties if you
access it on an app store of your choice
you'll encounter an image of a strange
skull-headed canine creature with the
following iconic description Mal o
version 1.0.0 free reviews zero
description never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again Mao o is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of Mao o you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is so quickly
becoming the next social substitute
remember the more you participate the
more Mal o will engage you your
experience is completely up to you
absolutely no ads enjoy Dr Siegel was
certainly eager to forget all his
painful emotions of disappointment and
embrace the new social substitute but
he'd read all the documents and seen all
the pictures on the file those who
download the Malo app will be texted a
series of photos becoming closer to home
over time both literally and
figuratively which show the strange
creature known as Mal o getting closer
and closer for some this would be a
complete nightmare for those inclined in
the direction of Dr Siegel it would be a
dream come true there was only one issue
they were just pictures but Dr Siegel
didn't get a job at the SCP Foundation
by having a lack of intelligence he'd
very quickly figured out a potential
solution to the digital barrier between
him and his canine Crush he'd buy a
burner phone download the Malo app onto
it and put the resulting infected device
directly into the Clockworks it was one
of the best ideas he'd ever had in his
own humble opinion but of course it
would all be about selecting the right
setting on rough the most likely result
would be the phone itself just being
transformed into a pile of broken glass
metal and a variety of conflict minerals
reduced to dust on course the result
would likely be the metal chassis of the
phone the front glass panel and a neatly
arranged interior gutted from within on
one to one considering he bought a
slightly older cheaper model of Samsung
smartphone he'd probably get the Malo
app on an iPhone and I'm fine perhaps
the best he could hope for was getting
Mal o version
2.0.0 which may have some minor
Improvement like the pictures appearing
twice as fast as they would with the
normal app experience Dr Siegel knew
that the only other option that could
potentially bring Mal o into the real
world was the highly unpredictable very
fine option which would either produce
the desired result or cause something
utterly horrifying to happen but at the
end of the day Dr Siegel thought to
himself isn't anything worth having also
worth incurring a little risk who dares
wins after all right he downloaded the
Fateful app and made his way into the
testing area for scp-914 he'd booked the
slot so it was all official but he still
felt his heart racing as he put the
infected phone into the input chamber he
set the control panel to very fine
exactly as planned and activated the
machine cogs twisted and churned engines
rumbled and sputtered pipes wriggled and
hissed it was clear that something was
going on here when the process was
complete and the output chamber opened
with a billowing carpet of steam Dr
Siegel could barely contain his
excitement he hoped that Malo would come
rolling out of the smoke like Darth
Vader and Star Wars A New Hope so you
can only imagine his extreme
disappointment when the chamber was
completely empty it didn't make sense he
thought everything through how could the
result possibly be so anti-climactic
this had gone from one of the most
exciting days of his life to the most
depressing Dr Siegel sighed and decided
to call it quits heading out of the test
chamber having no idea what he just
Unleashed onto the foundation across the
site Dr Alto claf one of the
foundation's most infamous researchers
was polishing his favorite shotgun in
his office he was whistling a cheerful
tune to himself just loving life when he
heard some strange rustling by the door
he turned around on his swivel chair
just to make sure it wasn't Dr bright
putting another bucket of battery acid
on top of his door as a quote fun
harmless prank instead he was shocked to
see Mal o an actual physical mallow
standing in his doorway grinning for a
moment clef was too shocked to even
react this didn't make any kind of sense
but when Mao o gave him a cheeky wink he
immediately loaded his shotgun and fired
blowing away a chunk of his own doorway
but sadly for him by that time Malo had
already darted away intent on causing
Mischief elsewhere its favorite pastime
Dr clef was still wondering whether that
Rascal Dr bright was somehow behind this
Fiasco but he was not because he was
actually about to become Mel O's next
victim in its ruthless reign of mild to
moderate inconvenience Dr bright was
swanning around the break room with his
favorite morning snack a coffee with
extra cream and a Danish from his
favorite Bakery in town he was looking
forward to enjoying these two Simple
Pleasures in his otherwise incredibly
stressful life but little did the poor
doctor know tragedy was about to strike
and nothing would ever be the same just
as the immortal doctor was about to
disembark from the room Malo appeared
right in in front of him giving him the
mild shock of his life it was such a
surprising occurrence in fact that he
momentarily lost his grip on his coffee
mug and his Danish causing both to
Tumble to the ground the mug shattered
and the Danish splattered by the time Dr
bright looked up Mal o was already gone
just like his breakfast snack Dr bright
fell to his knees and screamed
up to an indifferent break room ceiling
but Mal o was just getting started Dr
Kane pathos Crow was on his way from his
kennel
we mean his private quarters to the soul
extractor when Mal o suddenly manifested
in front of him this resulted in a brief
barking match between the two for
dominance over that particular hallway
which ended in Mao D manifesting to
bother someone else which technically
made Dr Crowe the winner though Crow
himself resented ever being forced to
act like a mere mutt how he began to
wonder had Mao escaped its app and begun
to harass the real world this would
warrant further investigation Malo
continued its Rampage of irritation
across the site intended to leave no
stone of frustration unturned and it
wasn't just the foundation staff had
intended to freak out it was just as
eager to go and bother its fellow
anomalies now that it had access to the
meat space yes that is a real term we're
not just being weird and gross we
promise over in the cell of SCP-173 the
sculpture three members of d-class
personnel were cleaning up the homicidal
creature's blood and poop they were
engaged in the standard procedure one of
them mopped while the other two kept a
close eye on SCP-173 to keep it frozen
in place that's when Mall o popped into
the cell behind them for a split second
before disappearing scaring the living
hell out of all three of them though the
Fright was of course secondary to the
fact that the second they looked away as
cp-173 snapped all three of their necks
oops may have gone a little too far on
that one a mellow but this newly
embodied burdensome Beast was just
getting started friends no anomaly was
safe from its new Antics next it
appeared in front of scp-682's acid tank
and made Rude faces at the hateful
Creature from the other side of the
glass this only served to sour the
creature's already utterly horrific mood
it thrashed around in the chamber
attempting to get out and perform an act
of great violence but by that time Maul
o was already long gone and scp-682 was
left grumbling in immense frustration
scp-049 the plague doctor was having
another very boring day he'd been denied
his animal cadaver test subjects for
several days as a disciplinary measure
after the latest incident and as such he
was Finding other ways to pass the time
today he was meticulously removing each
piece of medical equipment polishing
them and putting them in a neat line on
his desk in his containment chamber
scalpels forceps speculums bone saws all
wonderful shiny and pristine the plague
doctor found it to be an incredibly
calming activity so of course Malo
couldn't just let him be the
cantankerous canine driven mad by the
power of suddenly being able to interact
with the world physically manifested in
the middle of the containment chamber
and used its tail to knock all the
meticulously arranged medical equipment
onto the ground with a thunderous
clatter the plague doctor devastated
lifted both of his hands to his beak and
yelled Sacre blue in horror in that same
instant Malo once again disappeared
leaving the tragic doctor to start from
scratch it was a serious setback on an
otherwise lovely day cursive strange dog
creature he thought to himself while
bending over to pick up the pieces curse
you and your entire bloodline a group of
hardcore mobile task force members was
engaged in the comically manly activity
of playing poker while smoking in the
barracks and before you judge them for
that remember that if your job was as
stressful as being a member of a mobile
task force you'd probably smoke too but
their job was about to get a little more
stressful when Mal o suddenly
materialized and gave the poker table a
sharp kick sending the towers of poker
chips and decks of cards all over the
place before disappearing Without a
Trace yet again it completely ruined
their game one of the more junior
members asked should we have uh done
something about that a more senior
operative shook his head and said well
I'll do something when we get the
official call from up top until then uh
let's reshuffle the back in the site-19
cafeteria Dr Agatha writes Was preparing
to eat a delicious salad that she'd been
waiting all day to enjoy as we've often
established working at the SCP
Foundation can be an immensely stressful
job so you need to take the small Joys
where you can get them for Dr Wright's
this delicious premium salad that she'd
bought from Harris Teeter earlier in
that day was indeed a joy she even got a
fancy vinaigrette dressing for the
occasion before she took the first bite
she noticed scp-073 Kane approaching Dr
Wright smiled and gave him a polite nod
Kane waved back that our dear viewers is
when tragedy struck Mao suddenly
manifested in front of Kane propping out
one of its candid legs right in front of
where the hapless anomaly was walking by
the time Kane began to trip and fall
over Malo had already vanished but it
was too late Kane kept falling forward
until one of his metal hands landed
right into the bowl that contained Dr
Wright's salad due to his anomalous
abilities the salad immediately withered
away into nasty dead nothingness Dr
reince began to cry as Kane who felt
profoundly guilty tried his best to
apologize truly nobody in sight 19 was
safe Mao o popped up behind Iris and
ruined all of her photos Malo popped up
behind the immortal Hitler clone in his
cell and gave him a good kick in the
rear Malo even popped up right behind as
cp343 also known as God who smugly
replied I knew you were going to do that
my son needless to say it had been one
hell of a day Dr Siegel completely
ignorant to the chaos his actions had
caused around the site had cried in the
bathroom for 40 minutes out of sheer
disappointment he'd barely been able to
focus on the rest of his duties for the
day on account of being severely bummed
out this was a day he'd been looking
forward to for so long and it all had
been for nothing that evening he was
driving home on the highway listening to
sad songs on the radio thinking about
the fact he'd probably just crack open a
beer and get some sleep when he got home
he sighed again and looked up to adjust
his rear view mirror when he saw a
skeletal face with huge white eyes
staring at him in the reflection a quick
almost reflexive turn revealed a huge
black figure with a canine skull for a
face was indeed just sitting in his back
seat watching him it was so shocking
that he immediately veered off the road
and crashed his car into the concrete
divider in the middle of the road
breaking his nose and collarbone in the
process really a perfect cherry on top
for this kind of day Dr Siegel was
sitting in the hospital not long after
that with a cast around his upper body
this was also where he received a
bouquet of flowers from Dr gears with an
attached note saying he was put on
three-month disciplinary leave for the
irresponsible use of scp-914 Dr Siegel
looked up and saw that Mal o was peering
around the corner at him with its dead
white eyes it's Fang lined ma Twisted
into a permanent ominous grin at this
point Dr Siegel realized that being
chased around constantly by a demonic
skull-faced anomaly in real life wasn't
nearly as Whimsical as he expected it
would be in hindsight that probably
should have been obvious shouldn't it
though please let us know if you'd like
Malo to stalk you in real life in the
comments below you bunch of weirdos you
know how it is we put up a community
post asking for our esteemed audience's
opinion on a given anomalous topic and
when you give us the answers we make a
video like this responding to them it's
a perfect system it runs like clockwork
or more specifically like scp-914 the
Clockworks a fascinating safe class
anomaly that can transform anything
placed inside one of its Chambers in a
number of exciting and sometimes
terrifying ways we asked you if the
device was in your hands how would you
use it and before we get into some of
the great answers we select did here's a
quick refresher on how the machine works
when an object is placed or entity is
placed into its first chamber the user
has the option to select one of five
settings Each of which leads to a
relatively predictable result first
rough which completely destroys the item
often utterly disintegrating it and
turning it into dust there is no way to
repair such an item course is a little
less severe it dismantles the object
rather than destroys cleanly and
efficiently breaking it into its
component parts often in a manner that
would be conductive to the object's
reconstruction one-to-one is a setting
that replaces the object or entity with
something similar usually in size weight
or quality fine is a setting that
improves the item within reasonable
means rarely straying into anomalous
territory with these improvements and
the most mysterious and volatile setting
of all is very fine which improves the
item or entity in an unpredictable
anomalous manner sometimes to disastrous
results great so now we're all caught up
we've had to do a great power now let's
see if you can handle it with great
responsibility Sam Rosenthal said I feel
like it would be interesting to put a
musical instrument like a piano through
it on very fine it would be interesting
to see what the machine would consider
to be an improvement with something so
subjective edit it would also need to be
something very high-end like a Steinway
good choice so that it didn't just come
out as a nicer piano putting a Steinway
piano into the Clockworks on the fine
setting would likely result in an
improvement making it a finer instrument
with a sweeter richer sound potentially
also changing its model from a baby
grand piano to a concert grand piano
however putting it into the machine on
the very fine setting would be more
likely to make the piano come alive
turning its legs into limbs capable of
functional Locomotion and as for its
keys they kinda already resemble teeth
in a weird way so we're going to say
that's a no-brainer its keys are
definitely turning into actual teeth
that are ripping with deadly venom
anyone else getting Super Mario 64
flashbacks or is that just me Isaac Ely
said if most of the chains binding
scp-2317 have snapped then presumably
there is remnants of the chains laying
around the foundation could combine this
material with regular chains and put it
on very fine in scp-914 to create new
ones to restrain the Devourer of Worlds
something that's extremely important to
remember is that the results of a very
fine transmutation are always
unpredictable upgrading the chains may
result in them literally gaining a mind
of their own and trying to imprison the
known universe and if they do simply
become better chains actually fixing
them to the Devourer becomes the next
issue personally you're welcome to take
care of that one first Eddie Ember said
so I had a crazy thought I would put the
substance produced by scp-153 the sole
extractor through on one to one I'd be
interested to see what the Clockwork
would quantify as the equivalent to a
soul I think it would be different
depending on the the personality of the
Soul inserted like while one person may
give their soul for love another one may
give their soul for a chocolate bar well
if the scientifically dubious 1907
metaphysical experiments of Duncan
McDougall are to be believed Souls
despite being ephemeral weigh roughly 21
Grams if the Clockworks have a difficult
time qualitatively judging the value of
a human soul perhaps it would provide a
vaguely valuable item that weighs
roughly 21 Grams little heartless sure
but what can you expect it's all cogs
gears and pulleys Shane said I would be
interested in what would happen if you
took a drawing of scp-096 and put it on
the one-to-one setting would it turn
into a realistic photo and if yes then
could this trigger the shy guy to attack
you I would also check this the other
way around to see if you could get a
pick of scp-096 that doesn't activate
his Killing Spree while it's impossible
to know for sure we personally wouldn't
risk this one a single Photon of
scp-096's face is enough to activate its
raged State as the failure of Dr Dan's
scramble goggles proved so even if the
Clockwork produces an even half decent
true representation of 096 looking at it
will give you a truly horrifying death
sentence Alec B said I would actually
somehow get a part of scp-682's body
mass and experiment on it maybe
downgrading the 682 piece by piece
wouldn't let it combine together again
or maybe just upgrade downgrade or let
some parts of 682 as they were maybe 682
wouldn't be able to adapt to this not a
big chance though anything involving
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile is
going to be unpredictable by the very
nature of the cantankerous lizard itself
the big issue with trying to downgrade
682 piecemeal is that each part would be
likely to reform and adapt before you
had a chance to process the rest of it
X-Wing Knight said what happens if you
put one pill from scp-500 on very fine I
would recommend against any more because
there are not many but maybe it would
duplicate the pill but because I don't
know how you'd improve it as it already
cures literally anything or maybe do it
on rough to see if it gets broken down
to its components and see if it can be
reverse engineered all we know for sure
about scp-500 and scp-914 is that on the
fine setting it results in scp-427 a
locket with rejuvenating properties the
foundation are reluctant to do any tests
on scp-500 given how valuable they are
and how limited the supply is but the
very fine setting could result in
something amazing maybe a doctor capable
of curing anything you know the kind of
doctor that scp-049 wishes he was Mr
Arthur said it would be interesting to
put the researcher that presents the
scps on very fine maybe the machine will
make the researcher into one of the
writers of scp-001 the database hold on
you mean me
I want to put me in that thing oh you
definitely don't want to put me in the
machine at the very fine setting we'd
suddenly be capable of putting out a new
video every few minutes it destroy your
timelines and even if you unsubscribed
you'd still see the videos they just
keep coming There Is No Escape SCP
explained is eternal There Is No Escape
mm-hmm
moving on Dr Veronica said ah it
happened my request to be hired as a
doctor at the foundation has been
accepted how about taking scp-458 the
never-ending pizza box and putting it
through on very fine I imagine that it
may be able to turn into something that
can infinitely reproduce any food you
desire failing that maybe put a
politician through on the very fine
setting will that make them a very fine
politician or a very fine person that
happens to be a politician or will it
make them Senator Armstrong from Metal
Gear Rising huh pizzas and politicians
the two P's of conflicting emotions
putting scp-458 through scp-914 might
result in it turning into an entire
Pizzeria that gives away perfect pizzas
at no cost they'll have wonderful
service impeccable atmosphere and always
remember your name they'll even give
away free breadsticks and exquisite
garlic bread bowls for the table along
with discounts on the finest mid-tier
wine you've ever seen it'd be divine the
politicians on the other hand could go
in one of two ways maybe they'd become a
true champion of the people Guided by
Ironclad principles that they'll fight
tooth and nail to see actualized doing
right by their voters and the general
public treating their office with
dignity and Poise or they'll be the most
incredible silver tongue self-serving
conniving backstabber you've ever seen
endlessly devoted to winning office in
order to monetize their position raid
the country's coffers and run off with a
fat bag of Swag while the nation Burns
behind them oh wait you said very fine
chances are they can shoot lasers and
are maybe 50 feet tall too that's just
kind of the thing you need to expect
although the first descriptor sounded
like a normal politician George
simonovich said if you put
scp-1609 through on the fine setting
maybe it would restore it to its chair
form that is a possibility but given the
anomalous nature of
scp-1609 the vengeful remains of a chair
it's equally possible that it might just
become higher quality wood chips perhaps
mahogany oh that'd be real nice
Gustavo Abate said if you put two or
more things would they fuse into one if
they do would the machine separate them
back if programmed right I don't believe
that scp-914 would fuse multiple items
or entities that are placed into its
chamber you may be confusing that with
another anomalous technology like say a
teleporter but if a researcher is
willing to step into scp-914 with a fly
then we might be able to see for
ourselves whether we're right stupid
people said I think it would be
interesting to put one of scp-978's
photos through the fine or very fine
settings preferably one with an
interesting desire depicted like the Shy
Guy's desire to not exist it's unlikely
that even the Clockworks would have the
ability to tangibly change reality based
on the photographs of the desired camera
however on the very fine setting the
photo will at the very least begin to
move and heck maybe something will even
crawl out that's when you'll really
regret putting any photo of scp-09 six
in there the GC gamer YT said I would
insert a cake or some other type of food
on the very fine setting to see if it
would come out as a better version of
that food like a cupcake into a full
cake or better quality ingredients maybe
it would simply change the flavor and
we'd find out that there's some kind of
sentience behind the Clockworks allowing
it to have an opinion on flavors on the
fine setting everything you've just
described is likely to be correct on the
very fine setting on the other hand the
cake May grow giant spider legs start
spewing noxious amnestic fumes and begin
attacking anyone who isn't brave enough
to eat it and end its reign of delicious
well-frosted Terror happy birthday moldy
Doritos said what about y-909 from
scp-3000 on very fine interesting to see
an improved amnestic effect or perhaps
it changes the substance completely also
interesting if you put it through on
rough or very rough to see the output
probably just a weak an aesthetic or
perhaps just rat poison on very fine the
y-909 amnestic might be become so
powerful that just looking at it will
induce a permanent alzheimer's-like
state and its victims effectively
deleting their minds on rough it may
just break the vials it's stored in and
Spilled the liquid everywhere dark mega
5 said I'd print out a meme put it in on
the fine setting very fine might have
unforeseen consequences and post
whatever comes out for massive amounts
of Reddit Karma it is an honorable plan
we do it already in our own way whenever
we finish a video we run it through
scp-914 on fine just to make sure it's
at top quality and once we did it on
very fine and uh we'll let you speculate
as to what video that was down in the
comments Brado said I'm actually kind of
interested to see what would happen if
we put Keanu through the machine on very
fine would it just break
oh brato how can you improve on
Perfection Soul Rex the Sun King said
put my character sheet for DND into it
on very fine and just see what happens
just uh make sure the alignment is
changed to new natural or better before
doing so on very fine it's likely that
scp-914 would ignore the content of the
paper and instead mutate the paper
itself perhaps it would turn itself into
a deadly paper plane flying around and
Blasting little paper turrets and
air-to-surface missiles at its targets
and that might Veer a little more into
chaotic evil territory Devon underscore
gaming said I feel like putting in one
of my model tanks to see how it looks in
the very fine setting it's unlikely that
those model tanks would remain models
for long they may wind up full-sized
Foley autonomous and chasing you down
the foundation Halls firing lasers and
radioactive payloads they might even
receive air support from the paper plane
wylene mus Hill said what happens when
you put water in and set it to very fine
would it become water from the Fountain
of Youth or would it become the best
tasting water ever on very fine the
water may become a nightmarish
aggressive creature that actively seeks
out and destroys its human victims like
scp-3280 also known as After the Storm
though if we're extremely lucky maybe
life-giving anomalous water is in the
cards we just don't like to be overly
optimistic these days we've been burned
too many times wild night Studios said I
would input the Tickle Monster in it and
turn the setting to fine allowing the
tickle Monster's power to make scp-682
docile forever while it's too much of a
risk to ever try putting scp-999 into
914 if things went well 999 may become
so powerful that we'd never experience
sadness or anger on Earth again and
after everything we've been through
wouldn't that be a nice reprieve Joey
Rolfe said I would put in one of the o5
Council on very fine setting then they
would make better choices because
they're better than before don't let
them know we said this but personally we
don't think the members of the o5
council should be getting any more
anomalous superpowers aren't they
Ambiguously dangerous and powerful
enough already dysfunctional Dragonborn
said I'd put an ft into it on very fine
in hopes it turns into something of
value
you genuinely caught me by surprise
there with that one however doing this
might make their Insidious power grow
even stronger rather than worthless
jpegs they might instead become a rival
group the nft foundation which instead
of protecting Humanity from Evil instead
decides to display a level of evil that
Rivals even the malice of the Scarlet
King it's really not worth finding out
chosen Mosin said I put my resume in
turn it to very fine and see if I can
eventually get hired in my college town
this is a high-risk High reward move
putting your resume in on very fine may
make it a document that immediately
anomalously convinces potential
employers that you would be the perfect
candidate it may push things further and
make your prospective employers obsessed
with you they follow you home and watch
you through your windows they wish to
take care of you they wish to be wed to
you they will never leave you alone
after all it was an excellent resume
Swagger said I think putting hideo
Kojima in the very fine setting would
show something very interesting if you
run Kojima through the Clockworks on
very fine he might even be powerful
enough to design and release Silent
Hills on his own now we're still not
over that is anyone Hearth Fireheart
said a titanium prosthetic arm put in on
very fine predicted result of possible
prosthetic arm with anomalous Properties
or an enhanced titanium prosthetic that
can move exactly like a regular arm
while granting enhanced strength we're
always down for super powered robot arms
chances are on very fine it might even
get shape-shifting or immensely powerful
reality warping abilities so powerful it
may even begin to change the rest of
your body picture what happens to tetsuo
in Akira bunker said put a burger on the
very fine setting I'm very curious as to
what would happen to something as simple
as a burger all we'll say is we
definitely don't recommend eating the
burger after you've run it through it
may wind up eating you from the inside
once you're done DS said I would put raw
steak in the machine and put it on very
fine that way the steak will taste very
delicious and be very fine
[Music]
um
I'm beginning to sense that people were
just getting hungry when they started
sending these ones in and we definitely
don't think you should put a stake into
scp-914 for all we know it might turn
into scp-058 and get us all killed
Nicholas Lau said all right this will
sound disgusting I toss in a jar of some
of my own toenails hair dandruff spit
and tears then cover the jar in lead
paint put on the sticker saying warning
radioactive materials and come in with a
hazmat suit and a lead Shield put on
fine then Evacuate the room for the
object to appear okay
well that's one of the most revolting
answers we've ever received here on SCP
explained well done Nicholas it's going
to be a while until we can get this
thought out of our heads this is the
exact opposite of very fine and the only
person thrilled by this answer is my
therapist Ray parentel said a Nickelback
CD on very fine just like we said for
Keanu earlier how could you improve on
Perfection and there you have it folks
thanks again to everyone who sent in
their fascinating and um disturbing
answers if you want to be in the next
video like this keep an eye on our
community Tab and thank you for your
continued support you'll always be very
fine to us Panic had set in researchers
were frantic there was a buzz of
activity not born of excitement but from
sheer widespread Fear The Scarlet King
was coming nobody at the foundation knew
when or even how the Monstrous
multiversal Tyrant would spring free and
bring endless chaos with him but
everyone knew it would soon they'd all
had the same warning the same nightmare
in fact it wasn't just the foundation
either the entire world had shivered in
their sleep sharing in the bad dream of
the destruction that was yet to come the
Personnel of the SCP Foundation were on
high alert of course the organization
had been aware of the impending threat
of the Scarlet King for longer than
almost anyone else but that was part of
the problem through some anomalous dream
had by everyone on earth now everyone
else knew the foundation was less
interested in uncovering the source of
the Nightmare and more trying to
counteract its potential side effects
that was what potentially offered the
Scarlet King the power he needed to
enter into reality after all the more
people knew about him tried to
understand or to find the Eldritch
entity the more power he was able to
obtain we have an army one member of
personnel chimed in during a frantic
debate we have an almost unlimited
fighting force that are specially
trained to handle anomalous threats the
MTF are you crazy another argued the
mtfs are certainly not unlimited at any
rate the Scarlet King might be one of
the most powerful beings in the entire
Multiverse how can our troops even our
anomalous units even hope to stand
against that you're proposing sending
our people into a Slaughter they'd all
be wiped out in the moment one of the
other researchers concurred we need to
be focusing our efforts on the amnestic
rollout if we can distribute enough to
the population we can wipe their
Collective memories of the dream from
the other night they'll forget and that
should slow the approach of the Scarlet
King slow him maybe but it won't stop
him the first retorted full-scale
retaliation is still our best option
even now while we try to come up with a
strategy that could be enough to draw
him in we're willing him into existence
as we speak uh what about deploying
another SCP came a voice from the edge
of the group it belonged to Junior
researcher Jake Harrison a relatively
new member of the foundation who had
been reading up on files related to The
Scarlet King he knew that in trying to
understand and come up with a way to
best the murderous multiversal warlord
that he was inadvertently feeding him
power but Jake seemed to have stumbled
on the one solution that everyone else
had overlooked there was already another
anomaly that might have been perfectly
suited for defeating the Scarlet King
what do you suggest Harrison one of the
other researchers thought you really
think something like 682 would be
willing to work with us and destroy the
Scarlet king that's absurd I heard 682
is meant to be one of the Scarlet King's
Children another remark no not 682 Jake
argued turning to the researcher that
had just made a comment about the
entity's supposed children a group of
anomalies that we believe to have been
born of the scholar King himself but
you're on the right track we use scp-999
the group of researchers looked
dumbfounded at Jake he couldn't tell if
they were about to yell at him or they
would all burst out laughing to his
surprise they actually looked to be
considering his proposal it was widely
believed that scp-999 the adorable blob
of orange slime known as the Tickle
Monster was actually the final child of
the Scarlet king that's not entirely
implausible one of the researchers
answered scp-999 is believed to be an
Ultimate Force for good that could in
theory defeat his father ah the Scarlet
King is meant to be unparalleled chaos
the two could cancel each other out
another theorized but the Tickle Monster
sorry
scp-9999 it's an infant a child someone
else pointed out even if it could one
day beat the sky solid King it's nowhere
near strong enough to yet we might have
days minutes even before he arrives and
I don't know if 999 has the power to
stop his father then what if we could
make him stronger Jake replied a risky
idea of brewing in his head surely you
aren't suggesting suddenly a loud
rumbling rang out like an earthquake
only much louder and instead of coming
from the ground below the noise was
coming from the sky the foundation's
researchers raced in the nearest window
or ran out of the buildings they were in
to turn their gazes upward scored across
the sky above was a deep blood red crack
a wound in the fabric of reality itself
it was huge almost covering one horizon
to the next and everyone looking at it
knew what it meant that crack in the sky
heralded the approach of the Scarlet
King Junior researcher Harrison spent
the next hour impatiently trying to get
a hold of someone anyone who could
approve his proposal the o5 council were
already swamped with suggestions for how
to stop the Scarlet King each one
contributing to his rapid approach
eventually Jake made it through and
spoke directly with a representative an
underling for the o5 council listen to
me he urged I know this isn't your
department but I need someone to sign
off on this please the lives of everyone
in this reality could depend on it what
are you proposing the Clockworks scp-914
Jake answered we place scp-999 inside
speed up the process and make him strong
enough to stop the Scarlet King it was
an astronomical gamble using the
anomalous Improvement machine
constructed of a multitude of clockwork
components cogs Gyros gears scp-914 was
a device that could be used to enhance
or refine any object placed inside its
input Booth depending on the setting
items could be transformed destroyed or
vastly improved using the Clockworks
rough setting disintegrated to any test
subject while cores dismantled it to its
base components one-to-one replaced any
item with an almost identical copy then
there were the fine and very fine
settings the former would cause 914 to
improve any item and the later capable
of the same but with one key difference
very fine would refine an object even
more usually by giving it anomalous
properties Jake had read up on scp-914
and knew that the foundation had
permitted researchers to conduct tests
using the machine however following a
catastrophic test nothing organic could
be tested in scp-914 that was a strict
rule no biological organism or living
thing of any description was to be
placed within the Clockworks it was
Jake's hope however that desperate times
called for desperate measures surely
with the Scarlet King almost upon them
the council would waive the restriction
and allow as CP 999 to undergo
refinement the o5 council
Representatives voice cut out after Jake
made his suggestion there was a long
pause even without the pressure of
incoming Calamity the silence seemed to
extend for a painfully long time
suddenly someone else spoke up in their
place a modulated distorted voice it
quickly became clear to Jake that he was
talking directly to a member of the o5
council under a different set of
circumstances he might have felt honored
but right now it was almost as scary as
the threat of Destruction by the Scarlet
King listen closely Junior researcher
the council member said on the other end
of the Comm line you may think you
understand as CP 914 you may even think
that it might Aid Us in stopping the
current crisis but you are far far
mistaken you will cease this current
course of action immediately your
proposal has been denied but wait Jake
protested surely it could work I know
biological material wasn't permitted
inside the Clockworks but that doesn't
mean it can't affect living matter
scp-999 is a living organism if he
really is everything we think he is and
we just put him through the refining
process he could nove researcher
Harrison the voice part using the
Clockworks would mean we risk losing 9
nine nine what are you talking about you
appear to have a fundamental
misunderstanding of scp-914 Junior
researcher the council member chastised
it doesn't merely improve upon existing
objects but replaces them with a new
version it creates if we were to place
999 inside the creature as we know it
would be gone forever and if it really
is capable of stopping this catastrophe
we will then have lost our Ultimate
Weapon against the Scarlet King but Jake
trying to say enough every second we
waste discussing our options the more
power the Scarlet King is able to amass
so why don't we stop talking and
actually do something the young
researchers shouted giving in to his
frustration and losing his temper the
calm line went dead there was no one on
the other end anymore another rumbling
sound rippled through the building even
louder than the last Tremor Jake ran
towards a nearby window and looked out
in horror it was already too late the
red crack above had split open wider and
like a tidal wave hordes of nightmarish
creatures came spilling out raining down
on the world and commanding them sending
forth his minions in a flood of
Destruction was the Scarlet King himself
Jake was done waiting for permission
from the council he sprinted as fast as
he could through the facility past Panic
researchers fleeing for their lives
while security officers and MTF troops
abandoned their posts in the futile hope
they could survive the end of this
reality and all others Jake forced
himself not to pay attention he needed
to find scp-999 the playful blob was
often free to roam around the facility
improving the days of anyone it
encountered so all Jake needed to do was
find anyone who seemed happy despite the
catastrophe and scp-999 wouldn't be so
far away outside the world began to
resemble the nightmare that everyone had
experienced the night before cities were
burning as monstrous Abominations tore
through innocent civilians and ripped
buildings and cars to Trends reducing
every nearby standing structure to
little more than Rubble with frightening
speed and ease the Scarlet King and his
armies had been waiting for this moment
for centuries Millennia eons even and
now nothing could stop them from
unfueling Pure indulgent Chaos on this
reality they had their work cut out for
them subjugating and destroying the
entire Multiverse but that isn't to say
they weren't enjoying it people across
the Earth were being killed in droves in
the name of the Scarlet King he diverted
the significant portion of his forces to
attacking the SCP Foundation itself
while the boots on the ground MTF troops
the ones that had remained loyal were
usually a formidable fight they were no
match for the Eldritch armies of the
Scarlet King The Horde began to set free
other anomalies kept locked up in
containment either by accident when they
stormed the foundation facilities or
intentionally seeking out their cells to
Spring them some scps tried to stand up
to the Scout King and fight attack the
likes of the plague doctor the Specter
and scp-2800 all tried their best to
ward off the oncoming attacks of the
Scarlet King's foot soldiers they lasted
longer than those who decided instead to
run away turning heel and trying in vain
to escape the destructive reach of the
Scarlet King even anomalies like scp-106
who could escape to other planes of
existence or pocket Dimensions weren't
safe in hiding they were only prolonging
the inevitable the Scarlet king would
find them all no corner of the
Multiverse was safe and of course some
scps thrived in the catastrophe
creatures like scp-682 the infamous hard
to destroy reptile found themselves free
to exact revenge on the foundation and
Humanity at large of these not all the
anomalies gave away their allegiance 682
in particular was too busy killing
anything it came into contact with
whether they were human or part of the
Scarlet King's Army but other scps
gladly or fealty with the Crimson Cosmic
conqueror forming alliances with the
entity responsible for setting them
loose and joining the mass of
monstrosities he had Unleashed and yet
in the midst of all the chaos the
Calamity and the millions upon millions
of deaths one Junior SCP Foundation
researcher was still searching for the
wholesome orange blob Jake Harrison had
put all his chips on scp-999 and
eventually tracked the Tickle Monster
down the building around him was
crumbling attacks from the Scarlet King
and his minions bombarding every second
as Jake ran into the mess hall his eyes
instantly caught sight of the ball of
orange slime cowering under a table hey
hey he whispered hoping to coax it out
it's okay I know there's a lot going on
right now hell it's the end of the world
outside but if you come with me I think
we can fix it together come on little
guy what do you saying as if in reply
999 immediately leaped up out of its
Hiding Place Jake caught it in his arms
instantly feeling a wave of calm wash
over him thanks to the tickle Monster's
calming anomalous effect he tried to
stop himself from fully succumbing to
the good Vines that the gelatinous
creature provided after all he still had
a job to do and time was short the
Scarlet King and his invading Army might
have seen for the most part to be
indulging in wonton destruction
decimating cities and Foundation sites
killing humans left right and center but
Jake figured that if there was any
method to their Madness then scp-999
would be at the very center of it not
even the Scarlet King knew for certain
if scp-999 really was his offspring
maybe he had heard the rumors and wanted
to reach the Tickle Monster just before
it had a chance to stop him if it even
could if the Scarlet King believed even
for a second that his supposed son stood
a chance at defeating him and ending his
reign of terror then he'd waste no time
hunting the orange blob down his army of
nightmarish creatures would comb every
corner of the world until they found
scp-9 99 although they might not think
to look inside the Clockworks placing
the smiling slimy SCP in the input Booth
Jake fiddled with the controls for
scp-914 he never performed any
experiments using the machine before but
it was all pretty self-explanatory
throwing the dial to very fine he gave a
moment's pause looking at the adorable
anomaly in the machine the warning from
the council rang in his ears if he
activated the Clockworks he'd in effect
be killing scp-999 either that or the
Scarlet king would do it himself when he
found the Tickle Monster neither
scenario ended well then the Thundering
sounds of the massacre outside got
louder screams coming from innocent
people who were being caught in the
Scarlet Kings Carnage there was no
question about it if what Jake was about
to do really could stop all this Mayhem
then it was worth replacing as CP 999 to
do it with a deep breath he flipped the
switch the clicking and clacking of the
Clockworks component's word into life
were drowned out by the approaching
Tremors something was coming no he was
coming Jake thought the very fabric of
the building around him started shaking
brickwork and cement crumbling and
falling apart has a large hand fingers
ending and pointed Crimson claws
wrenched open the roof with ease looking
up in horror Jake saw that the sky was a
dark shade of red towering over it a
colossal crimson-clad Warrior looked in
on the frightened researcher horns
protruding from its head maybe because
scp-9999 was still nearby The Blob was
offering him some kind of positive
mental protection otherwise the mere
side of the gigantic monstrous being
above him would have driven Jake and any
other Mortal mad the Scarlet King was
upon Him
came a booming voice that sounded like
hundreds of Screams overlaying each
other the Scarlet King's gaze seemed to
shift slightly turning from Jake as he
lay helplessly on the ground to look at
scp-914 the machine had fully activated
and couldn't be stopped now either
through foreknowledge or some kind of
cosmic sense the Eldritch monstrosity
seemed to know exactly what the device
did
what have you done
the Scarlet King roared he raised a
gargantuan Fist and brought it straight
down through the air towards Jake he
couldn't run the Scarlet King was so
vast in size that there was no way the
researcher would be able to evade the
oncoming strike Jake raised his arms in
a futile attempt to protect himself
despite knowing that the Scarlet King's
fist would likely plunge through the
very surface of the Earth Below but then
again maybe the junior researcher just
didn't want to watch there was a pause
the strike never came it was only when
Jake built up the courage to open his
eyes that he saw what had happened a
long tendril of orange slime had reached
out of scp-914 forming a protective
barrier between Jake and The Scarlet
King suddenly with all the force of a
tidal wave the newly refined scp-9999
came pouring out of the Clockworks the
tickle Monster's Mass had increased it
was thousands if not millions of times
bigger swept aside and out of Harm's Way
by the orange slime the junior
researcher looked up in amazement at as
scp-999 reached up into the sky able to
look its supposed to face the Scarlet
King recoiled in horror as the Tickle
Monster engulfed him pulling the cosmic
Crimson plunderer into an Embrace as
they hugged there seemed to be a change
in the Scarlet King the Eldritch monster
had spent all his time since the dawn of
creation as a cruel nihilistic conqueror
he had killed and enslaved devoured
ancient gods and slaughtered entire
planes of existence in his quest to
annihilate everything but now held tight
by his gelatinous son his heart shifted
it was as if the Scarlet King's eyes had
been opened and he could see the beauty
of creation the sheer overwhelming
goodness of scp-999 enhanced by scp-914
undid the evil of the Scarlet King
himself only it didn't stop as the
orange slime engulfed the Scarlet King
in a hug he began to be unmade the
Tickle Monster without even trying to
harm father had been made into such a
beacon of pure positivity by the
Clockworks that the Scarlet King simply
ceased to exist he was unwoven not
killed but rendered without any purpose
he barely even felt any pain but at the
same time was removed from this and
every other universe and still it didn't
stop the newly recreated scp-999 spread
across the world like an orange flood
the Scarlet King's armies the other scps
even the few surviving human beings were
all wiped away
scp-999 spread to every corner of the
Earth turning the Blue Planet Orange as
he coded it purging every single scrap
of negativity all hatred all cruelty all
evil even that of the SCP Foundation
itself the entire world was unmade by
the Tickle Monster not out of malice but
so that nobody anywhere could cause the
Scarlet King to re-emerge at the same
time all that was left was a
planet-sized ball orange slime lonely
spinning through space there are some
people who would get tired of being
placed in charge of scp-914 or the
Clockworks the monotony of it all might
make most of us go mad the same routine
day after day placing an infinite number
of objects into the intake Booth of the
machine selecting one of the modes be it
rough course one-to-one fine or very
fine and seeing just what sort of
transformation takes place but there was
one employee of the SCP Foundation who
liked that routine just fine Dr gears
was happy with his position the
Simplicity of the routine the
predictability of it all he liked when
the days stacked neatly together in a
row of uneventful stretches of time it
was why he ate the exact same meal for
lunch every day a plain turkey sandwich
on White Bread a cup of water and a
single banana of course there was some
variety in the events that came about
when testing the Clockwork
there was that incident with Dr Curtis
and the pound of bacon placed inside the
machine alongside a photograph of
scp-682 it had resulted in a miniature
replica of scp-682 made entirely out of
bacon capable of movement and extremely
hostile though its size prevented it
from doing any damage it did still
attempt to kill any staff it could find
it had smelled mouth-watering but Dr
gears had suspended Dr Curtis from
testing with scp-914 for the trouble and
a day of having bacon grease cleaned off
of every surface in the vicinity there
was also the incident that occurred when
Dr Hertz in an attempt to score some
free music production placed a CD of his
own original guitar songs into the
machine on the setting very fine rather
than improving the production quality of
the tracks on the CD the machine
produced a completely silent CD as well
as a collection of books on songwriting
singing and playing the guitar for
beginners Dr gears had to physically
drag Dr Hertz from the room when upset
by the blow to his ego he attempted to
attack the machine and of course there
had been the highly destructive super
bouncy ball incident which resulted in
45 casualties and staggering damage to
the facility as well as the
aforementioned ball which was currently
thought to be somewhere in space most
likely orbiting Mars but for the most
part it was always the same thing an
object went in a setting was selected
and the object came out in a new
modified State wash rinse repeat just
like it said on the back of the bottle
of the brand of unscented shampoo Dr
gears had been using for the past 30
years that was how he liked it and as he
sat at his desk going over the test logs
and preparing to supervise another round
of tests he turned on some of his
favorite Tunes well I say Tunes but it
was really a white noise machine he
didn't care for music it was a bit too
much exciting he was just getting into
the flow of his work when there was a
knock at his office door
um excuse me sir a research assistant
was standing at the door pale and
anxious a clipboard in his hands there
um requesting your help with an
emergency down the hall what is it Dr
gears asked they didn't really say just
something about Dr bright and um
chainsaws the assistant stammered Dr
gears sighed and stood up from his desk
I'll be right there there wouldn't be
anyone keeping an eye on scp-914 but at
this point the experimentation process
basically ran itself everything would be
fine if Dr gear stepped away for a
little while wouldn't it meanwhile
across the site a very enterprising mask
became keenly aware of an opportunity
presenting itself it had been lying in
weight meticulously planning and
plotting for days and now there was an
opening it could take advantage of you
see months ago the mask had managed to
finagle itself a host a researcher who
had just been working with scp-914 when
the mask's Consciousness took over the
man's and it delved into all of his
thoughts as they were snuffed out one by
one it learned all about The Marvelous
miraculous Clockworks the machine
capable of transforming anything into a
better version of itself The Mask had
fantasized obsessed about getting to
scp-914 of using it to mold itself to
change into something greater and more
powerful then perhaps it could escape
this place and return to its former
freedom and Glory of course it would
have to select the right setting one
wrong choice and the whole plan could
amount to nothing on rough The Mask
would likely be destroyed reduced to a
pile of ceramic dust or perhaps even a
ball of unmolded clay alongside some of
the black slime always oozing from its
eyes and mouth on course it would likely
be transformed into a slab of plain
porcelain uncarved and unpainted on one
to one The Mask would likely be swapped
out with another anomalous object some
other enterprising mask or perhaps a
haunted Victorian doll or some other
malicious inanimate thing and what use
would that be no that wouldn't do at all
fine could be promising and would likely
prevent the mask from degrading any
future hosts it decided to take but why
stop there why should it limit itself to
Simply fine when very fine was right
there and looking oh so promising it
decided if it could get to scp-914 it
would find a way to transform itself
using the very fine setting and then its
enemies this pathetic Foundation the
entire world would fall to their knees
it had been waiting patiently like a
snake coiled and ready to snap up its
prey spreading its psychic tendrils as
far as they could go and anticipating
the moment that someone left
scp-914 unattended now the moment had
arrived of course the mask would need
help it didn't have a way to reach the
Clockworks on its own so it had been
wrapping its info influence around the
guards stationed just outside its door
dripping thoughts into his head
Whispering Darkness into his ear at
every chance it got chipping away at his
will bit by bit until the man was little
more than a puppet with the possessive
mask tugging at his strings The Mask
gave a mental Yank on one of those
strings calling the man in its thrall
into the room first he knocked out his
fellow guard with the butt of his gun at
this point his mind was so pliable that
he would do anything to please The Mask
next the man entered the containment
chamber a glassy vacant look in his eyes
he unlocked the glass case and reached
inside lifting the mask out and bringing
it one step closer to absolute freedom
he tucked the mask inside of his uniform
hiding it away from any prying eyes and
began to walk steadily towards
scp-914's room all the while the mask
whispered silent encouragement into the
man's weakened mind promising him power
and success Beyond his wildest dreams if
only he would help it achieve this goal
of course the mask was planning to kill
the man as soon as his task was done but
he didn't need to know that yet every
step brought the mask closer to Victory
and it was practically vibrating with
the delicious anticipation of it all
soon so soon they reached the
containment room the Clock Works just
beyond the door the guard carried the
mask into the room place the mask inside
of the intake Booth closed it and
approached the control panel in
accordance with the masks psychic
constructions he selected very fine and
turned the machine on the cogs and gears
inside word to life the engine sputtered
metal clanked and pipes exhaled hissing
bursts of energy the output chamber
opened and through the curtain of steam
scp-035 stepped in new and improved form
that's right stepped first one long
sinewy leg leathery shiny and black as
the night extended into view another leg
followed and along with it came a torso
a pair of arms a slender neck and the
familiar face of the Mask stark white
against the darkness of its new body the
feet ended in little points as if the
figure was wearing boots but there was
no visible clothing it was all one being
angular and strange with long long
fingers tipped with curved claws The
Mask let out a wicked cackle throwing
back its head in Triumph
[Laughter]
excellent it's even better than I am
The Mask turned to the guard that had
helped it Escape thank you for your
service now I have one last favor to ask
you it was time for The Mask to test its
powers to see how the Clockworks had
strengthened what was already there what
more it was capable of in this enhanced
State I want you to go into the
cafeteria walk into the kitchen and
climb into the oven would you make sure
you turn it on nice and hot first it
waited for a few seconds before the man
nodded solemnly turned and left the room
heading off in the direction of the
cafeteria it listened as the moments
passed and the sound of horrified
shocked screams rang out and it knew
that the man had followed its
instructions exactly at the mask's
orders he had cooked himself for lunch
the mass clapped its hands together
cackling again
[Laughter]
wonderful oh wonderful now that's taken
care of what shall I try next if the
mask had eyebrows they would have been
arched in a truly devilish expression
first it wanted to test its abilities on
a truly formidable opponent someone
worthy of the mask's time and attention
casually as you please it Strode over to
one particular containment chamber to
see about an unkillable reptile as it
walked several guards took notice
pointing their weapons at the mask and
ordering it to stand down each time it
chuckled and with the wave of its hand
the barrels of their guns warped and
twisted into little metal bows
completely useless it snapped its clawed
fingers and the guards fell to the
ground in an unconscious Heap can't have
you sounding the alarm yet the fun is
only just
The Mask remarked though it knew the
guards couldn't hear it it kicked open
the door to scp-682's containment room
with a jaunty greeting
hello you scary fool I come to pay you a
visit the reptile did not respond
incapacitated by its hydrochloric acid
bath that just wouldn't do the mass
concentrated and the steel chamber broke
apart acid spilling everywhere hissing
as it splashed onto any available
surface
scp-682 lifted its head twitching its
tail and took in the sight of the new
and improved mask what do you think the
mask posed for the creature laughing
again it seemed it couldn't stop
laughing lately its expression fixed
into a permanent gleeful smile it
couldn't help it freedom and power just
felt so good disgusting
scp-682 remarked unimpressed with this
display it lunged at the mask preparing
to attack but the mask held up a hand to
stop it not so fast
scp-682 suddenly froze in place eyes
rolling wildly as it tried desperately
in vain to move let's see what should I
do with you the mask was itching to test
out its reality warping abilities it had
the feeling that there was very little
it couldn't do in this state and wanted
to see just how far its power could go
but what would be suitable punishment
what could be the cruelest possible
thing to do to such a creature The Mask
could simply try to kill it to finally
snuff out this endless miserable life
but that would be a release that would
be far too easy aha a light bulb went
off and the mask's Twisted mind perfect
it waved its hand releasing scp-682 from
its paralysis but as the massive lizard
snapped its jaws and moved to take a
bite out of the Mask it lost its Balance
Falling to the ground its legs had begun
to shrink rapidly knocking its center of
gravity is skew soon the rest of its
body began to follow getting smaller and
smaller at an unbelievable Pace until
finally where there had one stood a
massive impossible prehistoric Beast was
something resembling a baby alligator a
tiny little tail thrashing about short
stubby legs bulbous eyes and a mouth
full of sharp but adorable
non-threatening teeth on the shrunken
scp-682 spoke its voice was high pitched
and squeaky
it roared yeah
you are the mask Turned and Left
thoroughly pleased with its work and
shut the door behind it now what other
fellow anomalies could The Mask exercise
its absolute superiority over it
pondered other supposedly dangerous and
deadly entities that it had heard about
over its time in Foundation custody it
all seemed so laughable now there was
only one true danger within these walls
and it was the mask oh what about that
abominable sculpture the ugly thing with
a penchant for snapping necks but only
when a person wasn't looking at it the
absolute coward cowards didn't deserve
to live the mask decided and it made its
way over toward
scp-173's containment cell inside there
were several d-class staring at the
Statue with wide unblinking eyes each
person terrified of being the one to let
their guard down and lose their life in
the process none of them would die today
however at least not at the hands of the
statue as the d-class in the cell
watched never once taking their eyes off
of SCP-173 the statue's head began to
twist and rotate the sound of cracking
snow and creaking metal reverberating
through the room the mask used its
telekinetic abilities to run the
statue's head from its neck relishing
the irony of breaking the thing's neck
just as it had done to so many others it
wasn't about justice of course the mask
had no taste for such insipid and human
things it just found the whole image
quite funny the entire thing began to
crumble apart like a sand castle beneath
an ocean wave disintegrating until all
that was left was a pile of Pebbles and
dust just like that
SCP-173 was no more as for the d-class
in the cell well the mask could use some
servants you are come with me the mask
ordered flexing its Iron Will and
quickly capturing the weak fear adult
minds of the d-class Personnel before it
they fell in line shuffling out the door
and following the mask with the same
blank Expressions as the guard before
whatever was left of their personalities
after so much time being used and abused
by the foundation it was gone now
replaced only with the will of the
mighty mask as the mass continued its
Victory Tour of the foundation now with
four mindless servants in tow it passed
the staff break room through the window
it spotted one Dr Bryant The Telltale
amulet around his neck microwaving some
leftover pizza The Mask had always found
Dr bright distasteful with a
self-aggrandizing pranks and general
dedication to chaos with no Grand Vision
behind it no meaningful agenda it was
pitiful it was deeply ugly and now the
mask had a chance to put an end to the
immortal doc doctors and ticks once and
for all it opened the door greeting Dr
bright with that Frozen grin
oh dog
Dr Bryant's eyes widened and he didn't
even hear the microwave behind him ding
signaling that his pizza was ready he
was too distracted by the horrifying
sight before him but as he opened his
mouth to scream to call for help the
mask reached out and ripped the amulet
from his neck the host body fell limply
to the ground and The Mask looked down
at the amulet glinting in the light that
held Dr Bright's Consciousness inside it
stared at the amulet with a flinty gaze
and under its empty stair the metal
began to rust to degrade and to melt
into an unrecognizable slurry The Mask
let it drip onto the floor then when all
that was Dr bright had melted away it
wiped its hand off with a napkin and
ground the wet puddle on the ground with
its heel goodbye doctor The Mask hissed
now what's next but as the mask turned
to walk down the hall it came face to
face with a disapproving face as scp-343
had manifested directly in front of the
mask and he clearly had learned of the
mask's behavior so far that day you've
been busy
yes very busy lots to do you see the
mask chuckled smugly you understand why
I can't allow this to continue right
343's expression remains Stern but calm
you believe you can stop me the mask
tilted its head to the side of course I
can
scp-343 side but you could stop on your
own if you would rather I prefer to
avoid an unnecessary conflict the mass
giggled uncontrollably of this
[Laughter]
I am going to run the flesh from your
bones
it's simply sad I thought you might say
something like that I'm going to have to
take your body I'm sorry
scp-343 prepared to teleport the mask's
new body to another location separating
them and reducing the mask to its
original more manageable state but
before he could there was sudden
darkness in the room every light
blinking out all at once the hall was
plunged into Shadow but this was no
ordinary Darkness this Darkness was Inky
thick cloaking like smoke clinging to
the inside of your throat then just as
suddenly as it appeared the darkness
dissipated but scp-343 was gone he
hadn't teleported himself to somewhere
else he hadn't walked through the wall
to get away from the mask he was truly
gone the mass couldn't be certain
exactly what it had done to a cp343 but
it knew that the enemy had been truly
eradicated in fact it was fairly certain
he had been erased from reality entirely
The Mask made one final lap around the
foundation containment site bidding
farewell to every anomaly it passed some
it transformed like it had done to
scp-682 taking inspiration from its
bird-like face the mask turned the
plague doctor into a crow others had
simply executed such as the poor
scp-096 whose screams and shrieks had
always irritated the mask of course the
foundation began to notice what was
happening and they tried to defeat the
mask they shot at it with their puny
weapons they sounded their useless
alarms and they called for their
laughable backup but none of it mattered
not in the face of the Mask guns melted
in guard's hands alarms when silence had
nothing more than a glance and more and
more Mindless slaves joined the mask's
army it didn't want to manage that would
just be difficult to keep track of but
in even dozen seemed like the perfect
number with this miniature Army in tow
the mask finally made its way to its
final destination the exit it had been
waiting for this moment dreaming of it
since it was first imprisoned so long
ago as it stepped out into the Sun the
mask realized that though it didn't have
nostrils could smell the breeze the
scent of wildflowers and grass what a
beautiful place to mold into the mask's
image of an Ideal World the world was
its oyster and The Mask long to swallow
it whole the current whereabouts of the
possessive mask are unknown the
foundation is doing its best to locate
the mask and determine new effective
measures for bringing it down and
recontaining it as soon as possible The
Escape of the Mask is being considered a
possible XK Class end of the world
scenario if it cannot be stopped the
best and brightest Minds that the
foundation are working on it aside from
Dr bright of course may he rest in peace
but right now there is very little
anyone can do so if you see a strange
dark figure and a white mask walking
down the street do yourself a favor and
run the other way before it's too late
panic and Terror gripped everyone in the
foundation facility while everyone who
is still alive that is guards were
working tirelessly to fight back and
regain control of the building but they
didn't have enough bullets to suppress
the oncoming horde somehow a sample of
scp-008 that was being examined for
testing purposes had managed to spread
to one of the research staff before long
the very same researcher was now a
Mindless zombie a reanimated corpse that
had managed to bite several other staff
members spreading the infection it
didn't matter that this original carrier
was shot down by security Personnel it
had already done it damage and passed on
scp-008 by now there were too many of
them to Simply Bonk each one on the head
and neutralize it the foundation
facility had gone into full-scale
lockdown an emergency quarantine to try
and limit the spread of the deadly virus
any exit to the outside world was shot
and would stay sealed tight until
someone from the foundation could do
something but that meant the few
surviving members of Staff trapped
inside were at the mercy of the zombie
horde their options were limited scp-500
was known to perfectly cure those
infected with scp-008 but with all exits
locked it was impossible to get any of
the remaining scp-500 pills on site then
one of the surviving researchers one Dr
omal had an idea it was an insanely
risky planned one that the foundation
would never sign off on but desperate
times called for desperate measures
Gathering up the remaining security for
forces that hadn't been infected with
scp-008 along with a research assistant
that had managed to escape the Zombies
Dr omell and his band of survivors
headed deeper into the facility while
the external doors were all locked to
prevent the scp-008 infecties from
making it out and spreading the virus to
The Wider world the doors inside the
facility were all still functioning and
it was a good thing too Dr omell's plan
relied on opening the doors to two
anomalies
scp-914 the Clockworks a machine capable
of destroying or refining anything
placed inside of it and
scp-049 the plague doctor it was a shot
in the dark at best homel had observed
the plague doctor for some time and knew
that the beak face surgeon was capable
of creating zombie-like creatures known
as
scp-049-2 not dissimilar from the
zombies infected with
scp-008 if anyone could potentially fix
this nightmare there were few as well
versed in anomalous medicine as
scp-049 taking him to the Clockworks was
however an even bigger risk normally
scp-049 killed any he touched and turned
their deceased bodies into
scp-049-2s hence Dr omell calling for a
refinement of the plague doctor's
abilities placing him in the input Booth
of scp-914 and setting it to very fine
omel prayed he'd made the right call he
could hear the horde of scp-008 pounding
outside the locked door what emerged
from the Clockworks was still
recognizable as scp-049 retaining his
beaked mask although the mask itself was
actually flesh and Bone a part of his
skull his robes now flowed out behind
him as a pair of dark feathery Wings
giving him an even more bird-like
appearance despite this
scp-049 had claimed that he'd never been
a bird before I'll admit I didn't expect
weighing the surviving assistant
remarked that's not so surprising really
Dr Romel admitted he did lay an egg that
one time he did what before an
explanation could be given the scp-008
zombies managed to break down the door
and came flooding into the room omal
recoiled in horror as they snarled and
shuffled closer reaching towards him
with decrepit fingers suddenly scp-049
swooped into the path of the encroaching
Undead with a flap of his new Wings
calmly he gave a gentle move of his hand
like lifting something from a shelf a
bizarre Contraption appeared around his
forearm a gauntlet connected to syringes
that were strapped to each of his
fingers all filled with various
different fluids Dr omell was amazed
scp-049 seemed to now have the anomalous
ability to summon surgical equipment
from a tiny pocket Dimension it was
almost exactly like how
scp-076-2 Abel drew his weapons reaching
towards the nearest SC p008 zombie still
moving with the utmost calm
scp-049 stated now try to hold still he
spoke in a gentle voice with the bedside
manner most medical doctors would be
incapable of This Might Sting a little
with that scp-049 pushed the syringes
into the zombie the fluids draining from
each one then refilling as he withdrew
his hands the scp-008 instance froze for
a moment almost like it was confused
before it began to emit what looked to
be steam as odd had stepped out of a hot
shower shaking uncontrollably the
necrosis and telltale signs of infection
seem to disappear like being washed away
until all that was left of the scp-008
zombie was the infected researcher it
had been before the man was alive and
well much to Dr omell's astonishment
scp-049 hadn't just cured the scp-008
infection he'd actually reversed it
leaving the the infecty alive and well
it took a few hours for scp-049 to fly
around the facility on his new Wings
effortlessly turning all the scp-008
zombies back into their old selves one
by one by the time he was done everyone
on site that had previously been exposed
to scp-008 was cured and it didn't stop
there the foundation still mandated
everyone who was previously infected to
remain in quarantine whilst they were
examined demanding the now refined
scp-049 to remain in his cell which he
politely complied with when the SCP
Foundation doctors took a look at the
formerly zombified staff they were
amazed at what they found each one had
all traces of scp-008 completely removed
from their systems trying to re-expose
them to the virus their bodies now seem
to be able to generate anomalous
antibodies that rejected and fought off
infection by scp-008 in a manner of
seconds the plague doctor had made
everyone immune upon further testing
examining skin and blood cells from the
former infectes and Performing full top
to bottom health checks the foundation
doctors learned something else too
everyone that scp-049 had cured was even
healthier than they had been before one
security guard had been a one pack a day
smoker for 10 years but an x-ray
revealed any damage to his lungs mouth
and throat had all been completely
reversed on every possible internal and
external level the formerly zombified
Personnel had all been returned to
pristine Health by a cp049 eager to
witness the full extent of these new
anomalous abilities the Clockworks had
given him the SCP Foundation struck a
deal with scp-049 if he performed a
mission for them then they would provide
him with the means to have anything he
wanted for a moment the plague doctor
pondered their terms and then agreed
what is it you want in return Dr omell
had
to cure the world doctor
scp-049 replied simply the plague doctor
flew as fast as his wings would carry
him to the location the foundation had
given him it was an isolated region in
Siberia kept completely cut off from the
rest of the World by guards working
around the clock arriving at the edge of
the Frozen town
scp-049 was approached by the security
commander and given his full directive
from the foundation irreductive I'm told
is simple you enter the restricted area
and neutralize anything you come into
contact with when you're done return
here and we'll report the results to
command thank you Commander the plague
doctor nodded graciously you have been
most helpful he didn't ask what was out
there really turned and began walking
through the snow until he could no
longer be seen by the eye maybe he had
already sensed what was out there what
kind of sickness plagued to this place
and understood exactly what the
foundation were asking him to do if
scp-049 had any questions he'd did not
make them known instead he just headed
off in search of every instance of
scp-610 he could find there was quiet
for an uncomfortably long while the
person outstanding guard at the edge of
the area washed through the snowfall
ready if anything started slithering its
way towards them the foundation's
security all tensed when the motion
sensor picked up movement accompanied by
the sounds of fighting and the bizarre
inhuman noises from instances of scp-610
then after another long period of
unsettling quiet somebody spotted a
gently glowing light making its way
through the snow as it drew closer the
glow of a burning makeshift torch made
it clear that the figure holding it was
scp-049 and as he made his way towards
the Rendezvous point it quickly became
apparent he wasn't alone shivering in
the freezing cold and wet from the snow
covered in scraps of dirty clothing and
whatever else they could find was a
huddled mass of people people all of
them looked bewildered following the
light of scp-049's torch like a guiding
Beacon towards the edge of the perimeter
the foundation security all stood slack
jot in amazement at what happened while
the plague doctor led the people and
urged the commander that they all needed
warmer clothing immediately he had done
it
scp-049 had cured the flesh that hates
in the coming months the foundation soon
found themselves very busy everyone who
had previously been infected by a cp610
needed to be screened and examined just
to make absolutely sure there was no
chance they could mutate into a fleshy
monstrosity again but just like before
with the former scp-008 zombies these
people were in perfect condition cured
and healthier than they had ever been by
using his new anomalous surgical skill
and healing power
scp-049 had returned the flesh that
hates victims back into human beings it
was starting to seem like there was no
disease no infection anonymous us or
otherwise that he could not cure the
foundation began an effort to re-house
the former scp-610 infectes given that
most of them had spent years as
aggressive anomalous Abominations almost
every one of them had officially been
pronounced dead and couldn't just go
back to their old lives the SCP
Foundation gradually reintroduced them
into the world setting up new identities
and integrating them into new countries
scp-049 even personally helped console
some of those that struggled with the
adjustment offering to give them therapy
to Aid in the process he was more than
just a plague doctor it seemed thanks to
the Clockworks
scp-049's good work didn't stop with
curing the flesh that hates either as
promised the foundation allowed him to
carry out his Newfound purpose whereas
before he was obsessed with eradicating
what he called the pestilence now the
plague doctors seem to be directing all
this Focus to curing the world as he put
it and he started with some of his
fellow and anomalies the plague doctor
started experimenting with his new tools
concocting cures and serums aplenty by
pulling whatever he needed from an
endless supply of equipment and
ingredients at his fingertips he
developed a cure for the condition that
caused Daniel McIntyre to become
scp-2800 cactus man his skin reverted
back to normal no longer sporting spines
while the plant-like parts of his DNA
once again became human
scp-049 even offered a sympathetic ear
to a lot of Daniel's troubles giving him
therapy through a lot of his mental
health difficulties
scp-2102 was also one of scp-049's
successful patients his condition of
rapidly overproducing new skin tissue
when injured quickly became a thing of
the past then the plague doctor turned
his sights to The Wider World working
tirelessly to create new vaccinations
and treatments for diseases that were
once thought to be incurable everything
he made and had the foundation
distribute to those that needed it was
all one hundred percent effective people
were healthier and happier than ever all
thanks to the plague doctor until they
weren't in attempting to eradicate
disease the world over a new strain of
illness emerged
scp-049 took to calling it a new
pestilence and it was nothing short of
horrific it would have been considered
anomalous at one time but it quickly
became so widespread that it couldn't be
contained all the plague doctors
Advanced Medical Treatments had
encouraged this disease to mutate to
adapt against everything he could throw
at it it could infect any person at any
time and present itself with virtually
any symptoms it resisted drugs any form
of treatment and it spread rapidly
eventually while trying to come up with
a way to protect people from the strain
of super bacteria this new pestilence
scp-049 started to fall ill he had
caught it and even with his his
refinement he was beginning to weaken
the plague doctor was dying and once he
was gone the whole world would soon
follow as more and more people caught
the sickness there was only one thing he
could do a way to leave someone behind
to carry on his work when the foundation
those that weren't yet ill found scp-049
had already passed but alongside his
body was something smooth and
pearlescent an egg and inside maybe a
chance for the world to be cured we
really shouldn't be doing this Adams
argued it's fine it's just a test his
fellow researcher Burton retorted in
protest the container procedures for
scp-914 come with a very specific
warning not to test biological matter in
it if anyone had found out what we were
doing we would both be fired or Worse
dosed up with amnestics and left on the
sidewalk somewhere with no clue who we
were Burton rolled their eyes Adam's
concern was hardly unfounded but when
they had to discussed the idea earlier
he'd seemed open to it then again it was
only a hypothetical back then now it was
getting closer to becoming reality look
aren't you tired of what we do here
Burton argued indignantly so many of the
tests we run end up with dead d-class
Personnel blood everywhere or just end
up creating new anomalies that will just
only go on to cause more people to die
I'm sick of it I don't think this course
of action is the best solution to that
though their colleague urged why not
scp-2800 is one of the few anomalies
either of us have ever encountered that
we can categorically consider to be good
he's not some heartless monster or
vengeful Cosmic deity he just wants to
do the right thing I already mentioned
it to him he's more than happy to
undergo the change and what if it kills
him Adams asked no what if it works
Burton responded sidestepping that
possibility entirely worst case scenario
he might not survive sure but best case
we could turn an ineffectual would-be
superhero into a tool to do some real
lasting good the pair of researchers
went back and forth until ultimately
Adams conceded it was hard to deny that
throwing any number of other scps into
the Clockwork refinement machine known
as scp-914 would easily yield far more
destructive results but scp-2800 was as
Burton rightfully pointed out a being of
well-meaning intense
if any average person were to wake up to
find their body had developed
characteristics consistent with that of
a saguaro cactus they'd likely seek out
immediate medical assistance but when
that happened to Daniel McIntyre he
immediately sought to use his Newfound
condition and the anomalous abilities it
granted him to offer assistance to any
person that needed it as the superhero
cactus man the spiked Menace
unfortunately when intervening in
situations Daniel proved himself to be
somewhat ineffectual as a hero although
this didn't deter him from trying now
housed in containment under the
designation
scp-2800 cactus man still continued to
offer assistance to the staff of the SCP
Foundation his behavior came as the
result of a few diagnosed psychological
conditions particularly his hero complex
a deep-rooted desire to help others no
matter the personal cost to Daniel
himself and it was this part of him that
caused scp-2800 to wholeheartedly agree
to researcher Burton's test unaware that
the experiment had not been sanctioned
by The Wider Foundation over here cactus
man asked as he stepped into the booth
labeled intake following researcher
Adam's directions that's perfect 2800
the researcher replied offering a thumbs
up before he turned away hiding his look
of concern shall we start with the
one-to-one setting researcher Burton the
hell with that Burton scoff we've got
maybe one attempt at this before
security notices he's out of his cell
and come here to find out what we're up
to we go big or we go home I'm setting 9
14 to very fine Burton Strode over to
the machine and threw the dial to the
highest of its five settings turning the
key below it wound the mainspring and
the entire device churned into life the
door to the intake Booth sliding shot
gears were spinning and grinding the
complex Contraption of over 8 million
moving parts starting its refinement
process belts pulleys gears Springs and
scp-914's other Clockwork Parts All
Began clicking and clacking while
scp-2800 stood in the intake Booth
growing more and more uneasy at all the
noise this strange machine was making
although the foundation had little idea
how its refinement process worked
scp-914 seemed to take any object placed
within its intake compartment and
disassemble recreate improve or destroy
the item depending on the setting its
control knob was switched to rough
completely obliterated an intake object
on a molecular level reducing it to
little more than dust coarse dismantle
the target into its base components
while one to one replaced it with a
similar item of matching design size and
quality the next setting up fine would
improve upon the base item although
usually without granting it any
anomalous properties and very fine well
you can figure it out from there you're
smart the last time a living being had
been placed in scp-914 on the very fine
side it had been a d-class and the
results were catastrophic a massive
containment failure numerous casualties
including the test subject since then no
testing of biological matter was
permitted in scp-914 but Burton was
convinced that scp-2800s in a need to
help people his deep-seated hero complex
and generally kind nature would mean
that the outcome was worth breaking the
rules
scp-914 was ticking and worrying the
noises of its components getting louder
and louder with each passing second so
loud in fact that it drowned out the
approaching clump of foundation issue
boots freeze hands in the air yield one
of the security team as they burst into
research cell 109-b where the machine
was housed the pair of guards assigned
to watch it laid tied up and unconscious
on the floor both researcher Burton and
Adams threw their hands up as instructed
struck with panic at being caught in the
act the foundation security Personnel
moved in restraining them clasping
handcuffs tightly around the two
researchers wrists suddenly the noise of
the machine stopped the guards all
turned their attention to scp-914 racing
their weapons training them on the
output Booth with no idea what was about
to step out Tim and Lee as the
compartment door slid open cactus man
slowly emerged looking around confused
as far as Burton could tell from looking
scp-2800 didn't appear to be any
different he cursed atoms under his
breath irrationally believing that he'd
somehow change the machine setting to
one to one during all the commotion that
is until one of the guards approached
cactus man to restrain him as the
security officer moved to cuff him
scp-2800's arm whipped around as if of
its own accord with the speed and
precision of someone with far more
hand-to-hand combat training that Daniel
had ever received cactus man gently yet
firmly swatted the foundation scarred's
hands away and turned him around it had
been so
easy so instinctive that scp-2800 looked
even surprised himself barely able to
believe the movements of his own prickly
plant-based body the guard tried to
raise his arms again only to find he
couldn't it was completely numb in fact
everywhere scp-2800 had touched while
deflecting him was the same a series of
long sharp Cactus needles from Daniel
had been embedded in the security
officer's uniform piercing through his
clothing and skin all the way to his
muscles and yet it was painless he could
hardly feel any of the sharp protrusions
cactus man had disabled him with such
Effectiveness that the pain didn't even
register his spines implanted in the
guard's body like acupuncture needles
then seeing what he had done with an
instinctive flick of his wrist
scp-2800 made the spikes withdraw from
the officer and they shot back through
the air reattaching themselves to his
body following the in incident and a
Severe reprimand for their unauthorized
use of scp-914 researcher Burton was
assigned to reassess
scp-2800's new improved abilities the
goal behind his investigation was to
determine whether cactus man had now
been rendered a more useful asset for
the foundation given he had retained his
need to offer help to others they were
looking to make use of him sure enough
the existing anomalous abilities Daniel
had exhibited before his refinement
seemed to have become much more
formidable Powers
scp-2800 had greater control over the
growing of his prickly spines as shown
when he first emerged from scp-914 not
only could he detach them at will as he
could before but he seemingly gained an
instinctive power to launch them as
high-speed projectiles neither recall
them or regrow missing spines at an
accelerated rate on top of that his
reflexes seemed to have greatly improved
as had his fighting prowess now able to
take on multiple adversaries without one
of them ever Landing a hit on him his
kaktakerous retention of water making
him able to survive on around one-third
of the water needed by an average human
male was also improved now scp-2800
could survive on next to no water
without drying out even a few drops was
enough to sustain him for an extended
period additionally no external Factor
could cause him to lose water his plant
cells were retaining even being in a
high temperature environment his
resistance to high temperatures typical
of many plants within the cacti family
had now evolved into scp-2800 being
fireproof he was unable to catch a light
even after direct exposure to Flame
additionally he had previously been able
to empathetically connect and
communicate with other cacti often
causing them to increase their water and
nutrient absorption now though cactus
man could cause his fellow spiked plants
to rapidly grow at an exponential rate
even producing cacti seeds that he could
command to grow the instant they made
contact with the soil or absorbed
moisture retained by his own body
despite the rules broken to refine him
the foundation now had their very own
plant-powered superhero ready to be
deployed at a moment's notice in the
event of a Containment Breach and more
than happy to help and it couldn't have
happened at a more opportune time over
the coming years the foundation granted
permission for cactus man to assist in
various recontainment efforts when
dangerous anomalies Broke Free of their
cells he ended up preventing the deaths
of a lot of the foundation's mobile task
force operatives as well as their
various Personnel purely by intervening
so they didn't have to put themselves in
Jeopardy however it was the eventual
defeat of scp-682 that allowed Daniel to
really make a name for himself as the
full-blown superhero he'd always wanted
to be nobody was sure how it happened
all that really mattered was the
Monstrous heart to destroy reptile was
loose again the crocodilian creature
famous for despising all other forms of
life had torn through the foundation
facility where it was being kept it left
a trail of Destruction in its wake
causing multiple subsequent containment
breaches and while the foundation
mobilized its forces to try to limit the
damage and re-establish containment of
the various anomalies now freed
scp-682 was making its way towards
civilization only to find cactus man the
spiked Menace standing in its path the
Monstrous lizard snarled at the sight of
what it viewed as such a pathetic
adversary even plant life especially a
sentient humanoid plant was an abhorrent
Abomination to
scp-682 civilians were running in Terror
of the hard to destroy reptile as it
made its way through the city
slaughtering any in its path and yet
scp-2800 was standing bravely against it
we both know they'll catch up to you
eventually Daniel called to the monster
as soon as though it'll be right back in
the vat of acid with he I know you're
not a fan of being locked up I'm not
either but you need to go back to your
cage
scp-682 started laughing a roaring
inhuman sound it didn't feel the
part-plane creature was even worth a
verbal response suit yourself pal cactus
man smirked he started calmly walking
towards the Beast as scp-682 began
charging its way through the street
hurtling towards its enemy still
scp-2800 Strode without breaking a sweat
not that a cactus can sweat but whereas
before he would have doubted himself
especially going up against something as
big and ferocious as the hard to destroy
reptile now Daniel was cool and
collected with two seeds in his palm
they quickly grew into round spiked
cacti that covered his clenched fists
like boxing gloves with sharp pointed
needles sticking out of them
scp-682 was almost upon him and launched
a vicious swipe with its clawed arm move
moving with speed and the matrix-like
reflexes cactus man easily sidestep the
oncoming blow before 682 had time to
launch another attack 2800 countered
with a kaktakerous counter move he gave
a series of quick Jabs each strike of
his fist Landing with enough strength to
reel the crocodilian creature and leave
sharp spines embedded in its snout the
hard to destroy reptile backed up trying
to create some distance between it and
it's surprisingly strong opponent but
cactus man wasn't about to let this
monster get another chance to attack
raising both arms he fired a volley of
his Cactus spines at the monstrosity The
Barrage of razor sharp needles shredding
through the reptile's flesh more were
regrowing in the place of the ones now
tearing through
scp-682 supplying Daniel with an
infinite supply of spikes to shoot at
the reptile as fast as it could
regenerate from the damage suddenly
still being impaled by the bombardment
of needles the crocodilian anomaly gave
a wild flailing swipe of its arm the
monsters claws cleaved ruts into Cactus
Man's Chest the aggressive move caught
him off guard for a split second just
enough time for scp-682 to thrash its
tail and sent him hurtling across the
street cactus man crashed into the
sidewalk with enough Force to crack the
pavement knocking down a Lamppost and
uprooting a fire hydrant water was
spraying up into the air as he tried to
will himself to get back up struggling
with his lack of arms until the cool
spray of water came raining down on
Daniel and instantly he felt rejuvenated
it was stronger and more invigorating
than any sip of coffee or energy drink
on the market absorbing sunlight and
moisture he renewed his literal green
fingers with more newly formed spines
protruding through his
chlorophyll-filled skin in seconds
cactus man was back to full form ready
to end this fight once and for all
turning to face the Sinister scaly
Terror that was
scp-682 Daniel nelton reached his hand
into the cracks he had left in the
asphalt his fingers reached deeper right
into the soil below while scp-682 began
to menacingly draw nearer it charged
again only to feel a rumbling burrowing
up through the very Earth beneath its
feet until suddenly something came
bursting up from the ground sending
chunks of Road up into the air over
turning nearby cars with the force of
whatever was exploding Up From Below
sharp piercing pain ripped through the
hard to destroy reptile's body at
multiple points its arms legs torso were
all impaled whatever it was kept
burrowing upwards lifting scp-682 up off
the ground as it climbed no grew out of
the earth a gigantic cactus had sprouted
up seemingly out of nowhere it was huge
far bigger than any on record the size
of a large oak tree and still rapidly
growing it spiked branches reached
outwards as it climbed and climbed pull
apart the limbs of scp-682 that were
impaled on its enormous needles
separated into several angry snarling
and thrashing pieces the hard to destroy
reptile was bested all the while
scp-2800 was concentrating on endlessly
regrowing the spines of its miles tall
Cactus he had created keeping scp-682
skewered long enough for the foundation
to move in and recontain the infamous
creature crowds of people had witnessed
the battle and filmed it on their phones
some even live streaming The Showdown as
it happened by the time the foundation
was about to initiate a cover-up and
start administering amnestics the name
Cactus man was already trending
worldwide on social media news crews
flocked to the scene rushing up to thank
scp-2800 for his heroism people were
cheering and clapping in their gratitude
and what's more when fire Crews and
Emergency Services began tending to
those wounded in The Reptilian Rampage
Daniel was seen aiding them he helped
clear Rubble use using his plant Powers
clearing damaged vehicles and debris
from buildings and offering to help
paramedics tend to the wounded all this
while watched by the adoring eyes of the
people he wanted to save it was too late
for the foundation to step in and sweep
this incident under the rug the whole
world had seen cactus man now and they
loved him of course that didn't stop
them from trying to recontain scp-2800
but when Shady vehicles and armored MTF
troops appeared to whisk their new hero
away people didn't take kindly to it
even while unaware of who the foundation
was or what they did there was a massive
public outcry for cactus man to be
released from whoever had taken him into
custody the foundation did their best to
ignore it placing Daniel back in his
cell for the time being that was until
the worldwide calls of free cactus man
grew so loud that even the powers that
be started to listen the governments of
the world slowly all started sharing
their own support of the plant-powered
hero who had risked his life for the the
safety of ordinary citizens he'd never
even met there were some who blame the
immense collateral damage caused by his
fight with scp-682 on Daniel himself
especially with the gigantic skyscraper
size Cactus permanently standing on the
site where the battle took place however
those detractors were eventually
silenced by those with the growing
concern of who would protect them if an
incident like that ever happened again
finally the SCP Foundation were put
under enough immense unignorable
pressure by the governments of every
country that knew of their existence
that there was only one course of action
left the door to Daniel McIntyre was
unlocked and opened for good and Cactus
man was free to go the world welcomed
him with open arms he was awarded medals
for bravery thanks to his efforts in
saving people by fending off 682 cactus
man graciously accepted and offered to
help out wherever he could anywhere in
the world over the coming years working
with intelligence and transfer rotation
provided by the foundation
scp-2800 was sent anywhere and
everywhere wherever there was conflict
or a natural disaster or even another
containment breach the world had a hero
ready and willing to step in people
adored Daniel with many growing
varieties of cacti in their homes to
honor his heroics and just in case he
ever needed backup should the worst
happen cactus man had become a hero
Beyond his own wildest aspirations but
despite being adored and revered the
world over saving lives was never about
fame or recognition to him the fact
remained that Daniel just couldn't help
it even before being put inside scp-914
and refined he had always held doing the
right thing above all else no matter the
impact it had on himself he'd risk his
own safety risk being beaten up injured
or worse if it meant getting another
person out of Harm's Way commendable
some might say but that compulsion never
left him even after ushering in a new
era of Peace
scp-2800 still wanted to help save
people but was there anybody left who
needed him to well there was just one
man one cactus man who still needed
saving over the years a considerable
number of innocent people had
unknowingly wandered into
scp-3008 otherwise known as the infinite
Ikea this extra-dimensional space more
than lived up to its nickname consisting
of an Ikea store with no known limit to
its endless aisles upon Isles of flat
packed Swedish Furniture but given the
veritable Labyrinth contained Beyond
these seemingly ordinary automatic doors
of scp-3008's entrance it was rare that
anyone making their way inside ever made
it back out alive on top of that there
was little the foundation could do to
ensure the safe return of anybody
unlucky enough to find themselves lost
in the infinite Ikea once inside
navigating a way out was made almost
impossible given the scope of the
spatially anomalous store and then of
course there was the staff these tall
humanoid creatures roamed the Isles of
scp-3008 sporting a lack of facial
features disproportionate bodies and
wearing the typical uniform of an
average Ikea worker I think it's
becoming a concern researcher Conley
declared no a problem just how many
people are going missing in scp-3008
what else can we do her colleague
researcher kylan replied shrugging their
shoulders we keep watch over the
entrance and stop anyone from entering
but ours isn't the only entrance Conley
retorted it was true based on evidence
gathered from some survivors that had
made it out of the infinite Ikea the
entrance seemed to exist in multiple
parallel universes say we could figure
out not just a way to navigate through
scp-3008 with better accuracy so people
can make it back out but what if what if
we could use it kylan jumped in
finishing the sentence it could be like
an interdimensional Spaghetti Junction a
hub to access all sorts of other
alternate universes we could send people
through the entrance in our universe and
they could make their way through 3008
and out into another exactly their
fellow researchers smiled one problem
though they said what do we do about the
staff the inhabitants of the infinite
Ikea were undoubtedly an obstacle
standing in the path of Conley and
kylan's idea The Faceless creatures were
known to be dociled during the daytime
cycle within scp-3008 only to turn
violent and attack anyone present when
the light dimmed they're part of the
problem Conley news but what if they
could be part of the solution the SCP
Foundation hadn't had much chance to
examine a live instance of a staff
member known as
scp-3008-2s up close as such they had a
limited understanding of exactly what
these creatures truly were beyond the
few they had witnessed chasing survivors
out of the entrance were they
intelligent they were apparently able to
speak if only uttering the phrase the
store is now closed please exit the
building did they have the capacity for
independent thought Free Will and
emotionality there was only one way to
find out and so Conley presented her
plan to capture a member of scp-3008
staff for closer examination not knowing
the bizarre chain of events that would
unfold as a result drawing it out was
the easy part of the plan after all the
foundation knew that
scp-3008-2s were able to react to the
presence of human beings within the
infinite Ikea so Conley proposed sending
in a single member of d-class personnel
with a line of cable attached to them
tethering them to just outside the
entrance of 3008. they were like the
bait on the end of an interdimensional
fishing line and would hopefully catch
the attention of a staff member and lure
them out what do we do once it's out
kylan had me used I mean we know so
little about their biology we could use
knockout gas but what if they don't
breathe we could tranquilize it but what
if they they don't have blood it had
been the one hitch in Conley's plan
although she had suggested they use pure
Force trapping the staff member like a
wild animal before bringing it back and
sure enough as an instance of
scp-3008-2 came racing out of the
infinite IKEA hot on the heels of the
d-class foundation security officers
were able to swoop in and capture the
creature restraining it and bundling it
into a transport back to the site
however upon receiving their captive
staff member kylan and Connolly were
faced with a new problem the creature
seemed to be in its passive state it
didn't seem to be aggressive while away
from scp-3008 kylan had posited their
theory that the staff's attack state was
linked somehow to the day and night
cycles within the infinite Ikea and now
separated from that space the
scp-3008-2 would remain docile but the
larger issue was communicating with it
as patient as commonly tried to be with
the faceless mouthless humanoid it
seemed to be totally unresponsive of to
verbal communication any question she or
her colleague kylan asked the staff
member it offered no response dialing it
back to more basic methods of
communication it didn't react when
presented with symbols unfazed by
letters or numbers or even
straightforward pictograms no matter
what they tried the staff member they
had captured seemed not unwilling but
unable to respond there's got to be
something we haven't tried Conley urged
her frustration building after a long
day of trying to get through to the
creature they're capable of speech we
know that from witness reports well
maybe they're a hive mind kylan mused
equally exhausted after their efforts
what if it shares a Consciousness with
the other staff like a drone in an ant
colony hey that's why we should name
this one they added D for drone can we
focus here please researcher calmly
snapped it's almost like we need some
way of enhancing it granting it the
right higher brain function so it has
the ability to speak with us hold up her
colleague replied you said we need a way
to enhance it but what if we refined it
what kylan was insinuating was obvious
I'll be at a direct violation of the
foundation's own rules
scp-914 otherwise known as the
Clockworks was an anomalous Contraption
of Unknown Origin two booths connected
to the machine one labeled input and the
other output could be used to
disassemble recreate improve or destroy
an object that was placed within scp-914
although there was yet again another
hurdle Conley and kylan would have to
attempt jumping over the foundation had
banned the use of the Clockworks on
biological organisms the pair submitted
a request to their Foundation superiors
for access to 914 and permission to use
it on D kylan hadn't expected their
suggestion to be met with anything short
of a resounding no and while determined
Conley couldn't help but find herself
worrying about the possible highly
likely rejection which made it all the
more surprising that the request was not
only granted but the experiment approved
by the o5 council themselves clearly the
highest Opera operational staff within
the foundation had some Keen interest in
whether the Clockworks could refine an
scp-3008 staff member more likely their
interest was in what benefit the
experiment could potentially lead to if
the foundation possessed a refined staff
member its own agent within the infinite
Ikea the possibilities could be of great
advantage to the o5 council they were
less concerned with having an
intermediary using D to communicate with
the other
scp-3008-2s or negotiating the potential
release of the displaced innocent people
lost inside the infinite Ikea if
refining D could mean the council had a
way to safely reach other alternate
universes by traversing through scp-3008
then that bridge between worlds would be
Theirs to control of course kylan and
Connolly were more interested in what
refining D could tell them about the
staff and the nature of scp-3008 did
instances of scp-3008-2 have needs or
wants could they even possess the
capacity to want things would they
fulfilled with their lives as anomalous
Ikea workers and how did they navigate
The Maze of endless Isles imagine it
Conley theorized if Dee can communicate
with them for us we could open up trade
with them the canteen inside scp-3008
endlessly refills with food just picture
what this could mean if we work out a
system of Distributing that resource out
of the Ikea it could change the world
she exclaimed excitedly only one way to
find out right kylan replied they
watched as D their captive staff member
was nudged into the input Booth of
scp-914 calmly gave the research
assistants a signal to activate the
Clockworks hoping that refining D would
allow them to be capable of speech and
free thought however either through
miscommunication or a Secret order from
above one of the assistants had
incorrectly calibrated scp-914 it was
meant to be set to fine which would
improve whatever was placed in the
machine but instead the dial had been
turned to very fine which improved the
target item to an Ever greater extent
often granting it anomalous properties
before anyone even noticed the change
the gears and Gyros of scp-914 clicked
and word into life making a raucous
noise of moving mechanical Parts
destroyed in the input Booth only to be
reconstituted into something altogether
new in the output 1 opposite de-emerged
from scp-914 after the process was
complete its clothing seemed to have
experienced the most noticeable change
instead of being the usual yellow shirt
and blue trousers Ikea uniform worn by
the rest of the staff D was now sporting
the same clothes but the colors seemed
to be shifting almost like the natural
camouflage of a chameleon they were
still faceless their body still
incorrectly proportioned compared with a
human and for the most part D seemed
unchanged but before kylan and Connolly
could move in to take a closer look
before they were even able to check if D
could speak the staff member vanished in
the blink of an eye an instant state of
panic erupted throughout the foundation
facility alarms were howling over a
Containment Breach security teams were
dashing through every wing of the site
to track down D swept up in the chaos
that quickly ensued Conley and kylan
received another message from the
highest point of the chain of command
find that staff member and bring it in
alive or there would be hell to pay from
the o5 council but somehow there was no
sign of D anywhere in the facility they
had gone scans of the building revealed
that all members of personnel all
anomalies and other registered forms of
life were all accounted for it was only
when kylan ran through the mess hall
that they realized where there were fine
test subject had gone to hey turn that
up they yelled to a security officer who
had been quietly enjoying his lunch
break standing on a chair he reached up
and raised the volume of a TV that was
mounted to the wall overlooking the mess
hall the screen was depicting a live
news report the anchor on the ground
standing outside the entrance to an
ordinary IKEA store I'm standing outside
the very store where this bizarre turn
of events have taken place being anchor
explained police received numerous calls
regarding sightings of an unknown figure
said to be scaring Shoppers however they
only responded when this clip went viral
on social media the report cut two cell
phone footage of none other than D
inside the store their uniform had
shifted into its typical Ikea colors
almost like it had adapted to suit the
place it had somehow transported itself
to from the mess hall kylan watched the
footage in a mix of shock and confusion
naturally the reaction from bystanders
was one a fright at the individual's
rather odd faceless appearance some took
to Twitter posting images calling it
some form of viral marketing hoax others
claimed it was a publicity stunt by Ikea
to boost sales although in a statement
the company denies these accusations
however it was then reported that the
supposed creature began I'm reading this
right aren't I the anchor paused for a
moment started helping customers by
directing them to store departments
recommending different Ikea furniture
and perhaps strangest of all did all
this via oh come on really telepathic
communication Conley had appeared in the
mess hall just in time to witness the
news Dee had gotten free and immediately
sought out the nearest IKEA to work
there the next few hours contained a
maddening slew of new information
bombarding the foundation as researchers
kylan and Connolly scrambled to figure
out some way of recapturing D it didn't
seem that the
scp-3008-2 instance was a danger to
civilians in fact most reports stated
that they were rather friendly any
customers that interacted with the
creature described its new communication
patterns in five star reviews they
apparently felt compelled to start
posting online I've never experienced
anything like it one wrote D offered the
most delightful customer service I have
ever received that's why they must have
gotten their name d for delightful it's
not like d speaks in your head another
review explained it's more like they
just give you their thoughts being
directly in there I said where can I
find the bathrooms and fittings
department and instantly Dee had given
me the directions it was as if I'd
always known having an anomaly like d
out in the open raced all sorts of
problems for the foundation for one they
would not have to only scrub every
mention of the staff member from the
internet but also track down anyone that
had interacted with d to administer
amnestics but that was far from the
worst of it the researchers had been so
caught up in coordinating a recapture
effort that they didn't realize how
rapid and extremely widespread the D
reviews were getting they were being
left on customer satisfaction boards for
stores in different states within
minutes of each other it took only 15
minutes for a review that mentioned Dee
to be left in a store that wasn't even
an Ikea outlet but a convenience store
thank you D for such lovely and Speedy
service at the cashiers desk never had
such a nice conversation and interaction
with anyone else in the store before the
review read the news that D could
seemingly be in multiple places at once
appearing in different stores was
confirmed when Conley and kylan saw
photos posted online of the creature
wearing what looked like a number of all
alternate uniforms it seemed that Dee's
clothing once exclusively just an Ikea
shirt and pants switched to match the
uniform of whichever store they started
to work in and the more they worked the
more places they seemed to appear
perhaps the most shocking development
came almost 50 minutes after d had been
refined and had disappeared once again
turning their attention to the news
researcher kylan watched as the manager
of a huge Supermarket franchise store
appeared giving an interview live
talking about how the altered scp-3008
staff had caused him to change his
entire business practice listen D is
great our customers love D I hear the
company's shareholders love him too one
thing's clear we all love D you said
jovialy but something was unnerving
about his gleeful smile so to show them
our appreciation I am hereby announcing
that effective immediately all my retail
staff are no longer required to come
into work he does it all so there's no
need for anyone else they're friendly or
quieter they work faster and they're
more efficient than any employee on my
payroll that's right folks d he's here
to stay naturally this move Sparks
serious controversy with the stores
disgruntled now former employees finding
themselves out of work a number of them
took to social media in an outcry of
dissatisfaction this isn't unfair I've
worked every weekend through college at
that store and now I'm fired just like
that thanks a lot Dee one of them
protested it's all corporate Ploy
another wrote the rumor is that the only
reason they're laying us all off so
quick is because D doesn't technically
count as a human employee so they don't
have to pay them they're working for
free so the store manager and the
company that owns the store can keep
every penny of the profits the Justified
outrage seemed to go willfully ignored
as another store announced it would be
adopting the same policy firing all its
staff and letting Dee take over their
duties more and more photos started
pouring in right before Conley and
kylan's eyes of multiple refined
scp-3008-2 instances working behind
cashier's desks refilling shelves with
products assisting customers these seem
to be acting out of instinct like they
couldn't help being staff it was their
purpose the horde of anomalous staff
members ended up swarming over the
country's retail industry simultaneously
like the drones of an ant colony kylan
what the hell have we done on Connolly
asked staring in disbelief at the TV
screen we've done the unthinkable they
answered equally horrified we created a
monster we took D out of scp-3008 and
made them into the most powerful retail
worker on the planet within hours every
retail outlet of every different
description not just Ikea had reported
the firing of their entire staff and
every business that did was now raking
in record profits droves of Shoppers
flocked to stores all enjoying Dee's
customer service so much that they were
taking any excuse they could to rush out
and buying well anything as stock
supplies started to deplete more and
more instances of the altered
scp-3008-2 appeared taking over the
supply chain and distributing products
to the various stores they were working
at refilling the shelves in record time
naturally the o5 council was Furious
researchers kylan and Connolly had hoped
to present them with a refined scp-3008
staff member that could allow them to
better understand the infinite Ikea now
the council's ulterior motive of having
access to an interdimensional Bridge of
other universes had been dashed as if
that wasn't bad enough and the added
hassle of D rapidly becoming a worldwide
sensation the economy was destabilizing
thanks to the retail companies firing
their staff and hoarding massive amounts
of profit from all their stores and
thanks to having decompulsively working
there refining an scp-3008 staff member
looked like it was about to collapse the
stock market and plunge the whole world
into chaos
um our bad researcher kylan Shrugged
unsure what to say after they and
Connolly had just been brought before
the shadowy 05 Council to be reprimanded
there was only one thing for it D had to
be taken out of the picture and quickly
the more they worked the more they
seemed to be able to multiply and spread
then with a greater number of D
instances within a store the faster and
more efficient they were able to work so
in retaliation the o5 council
begrudgingly activated mobile task for
alpha 1 better known by their code name
red right hand this task force reported
directly to the council there were some
of the foundation's most loyal
operatives and it was far from their
first assassination mission well they
had assumed it would be an assassination
dispatching the red right hand to a
nearby Ikea where D had first
transported themselves to After exiting
914. of course the place was overrun
with d duplicates but even after
clearing out the entire store and
administering amnestics to any customers
that witnessed it there were still
plenty more of D out there the council
quickly realized that they'd have to
send MTF Alpha 1 to every branch of
every Outlet in the country
systematically taking out every
duplicate of D in a lengthy cleanup
operation until they were no more it
seemed the foundation's Personnel had
their work cut out for them hopefully
they'd be entitled to a raise and some
paid time off after all of this was over
Russell's Back was pressed against the
wall his shuttering hands gripping the
fire ax the low emergency lighting
filling the corridor indicated the
lockdown was still in effect although
that was simultaneously a blessing and a
curse sure it meant that thing couldn't
get out hopefully but it also meant that
Russell was stuck in the wing of the
facility with it he had no idea if
anyone else was left he hadn't seen what
had happened to Carpenter maybe it got
him or perhaps he had managed to give it
the slip at the last second there was no
way of knowing for sure it had all
started so simply so innocently and with
such Noble intentions if he had known it
would lead to all this madness Russell
would have never put his name down on
the request form the SCP Foundation had
been working on a way to neutralize or
cure scp-610 for what felt like forever
to one team of scientists the infamously
so-called flesh that hates was a
fascinating organism it was a highly
contagious sarcic skin disease isolated
entirely within the small area of
Siberia that on its own wasn't enough to
Peak the interest of the research team
led by Dr Carpenter including his
hand-picked star researchers Russell and
David along with their assistant clennan
and Dr bottin an expert on infectious
diseases who had recently joined their
efforts to provide his specialist
knowledge what did Captivate all of them
however was what scp-610 did when it
infected a human being the disease would
trigger aggressive and uncontrollable
mutations within its infected and could
virtually rewrite their entire
physiology in a heartbeat the flesh that
hates was capable of transforming a
person's body into a horrifying fleshy
mass of Limbs and matter that barely
resemble the human being anymore and in
addition the infected individuals would
retain some level of awareness attacking
any uninfected person with extreme
hostility there had long been chatter
among some other research teams studying
scp-610 about device a way to weaponize
the disease if they could somehow create
a variant that didn't turn people into
monsters or at least caused the fleshy
Abominations to die shortly after
mutation then the foundation or another
interested party could deploy the flesh
that hates as a biological weapon Dr
Carpenter had long abhorred the idea
instead searching for a way to
completely reverse the effects of an
scp-610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
hope researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried treating scp-610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr button's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another SCP
Russell brought this hypothesis to the
rest of the research team and each of
them had suggestions for other anomalies
they could potentially use to cure a
subject of the flesh that hates we could
get scp-049 to take a look at the
infected patient clennan suggested well
might work carpents are mused although
even if he cares someone he might also
kill them he has his whole deal about
ridding the world of the pestilence
could prove to be a problem there's
always 682 David said dryly have the
reptile eat up all the scp-610
infectives and voila problem solved a
real helpful David researcher Russell
retorted and what are we gonna do when
scp-682 adapts to the flesh you really
want an infected Immortal lizard on the
loose Gentlemen please Dr Button spoke
up we're forgetting one obvious option I
propose we submit a joint formal request
to use scp-914 for this experiment
unanimously the group all agreed that
this was the best course of action
scp-914 or the Clockworks was a giant
machine with two boots marked input and
output although the foundation still
couldn't fully comprehend exactly how as
cp914 seemed to take any object placed
within it and disassemble recreate
improve or destroy the item depending on
its current setting there was one issue
however a prior failed experiment where
in a d-class was placed in scp-914 had
led to some pretty disastrous
consequences as a result ever since no
organic matter was to be placed within
the Clockworks a rule that the teams
experiment with the flesh would breach
still they pressed on each of the five
researchers signing their request to
utilize scp-914 before it was submitted
to the foundation higher-ups within
hours the request was denied but the
team was determined that scp-914 could
be the key to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with scp-610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision
urging the higher-ups to reconsider he
argued that this flouting of the no
organic matter rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the flesh
that hates after a few days of
consideration the request was finally
Faithfully granted the team went to work
immediately requisitioning two test
subjects both of which had suffered
scp-610 infections and were horribly
mutated the pair of them were deemed a
potential Hazard to every member of
foundation staff on site and as a result
the entire wing of the facility where
the Clockworks was house had to be
evacuated for safety dressed in
biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
coax the first flash specimen into the
input chamber of scp-914 this was the
test run they wanted to see if the
Clockworks would actually be able to
affect those infected with scp-610 at
all plus they needed a Fail-Safe just in
case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked Clement to set the Clockworks to
rough and with a click in War of its
numerous gears and Gyros
scp-914 came to life instantly the
infected test subject was completely
obliterated the setting had reduced it
to atoms disintegrating it on such a
microscopic level that there was nothing
left in the output chamber the second
infected creature seemed to bristle with
anger but didn't attack or become
aggressive as it too was plotted towards
the Clockworks next perhaps out of fear
that their Theory might be wrong the
team agreed to set scp-914 to its
one-to-one setting sure enough the
machine recreated another instance of a
specimen infected with the flesh that
hates
replacing the previous one we all know
we're stalling researcher David piped up
let's do what we came here for set the
Clockworks to coarse nervously receding
a nod from Dr Carpenter Lennon stepped
forward to switch the dial on scp-914 to
the course setting this was the primary
reason the team had all agreed to use
the machine on a flesh specimen this
setting could disassemble any item
placed in the input Booth separating it
into its base components botton had
suggested the use of scp-914 based on
the theory that if it worked correctly
the Clockworks could extract the flesh
that hates from its infected host
rendering them free of the disease the
machine made a colossal amount of noise
as clennan hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the dial hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to very
fine the highest refinement set 914 had
what the hell have you done Carpenter
yelled at clennan before the machine
suddenly activated would step free from
the output Booth stunned the researcher
it was a man a seemingly ordinary human
who had presumably been infected by
scp-610 some time ago he stepped
nervously out of the machine looking
confused for a moment as a pair of
foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became a part of
it the guards arms and legs forming
additional limbs as their forms were
reconstituted and repurposed as part of
a monster that was now crawling on its
six legs towards the research team in a
blind panic the group scrambled for the
entrance the head of the infected man
splitting open down the middle of
opening up into a wide snapping pair of
Jaws panting hard as he ran his breath
fogging up the clear faceplate of The
Biohazard suit Russell ran through the
door hearing someone close behind he
stopped for a moment looking back to see
the creature on the other side of the
door starting to spill through the door
frame like a liquid running faster
around a corner Russell came to another
halt in the common area a third security
guard following just before a thick
Steel security door came slamming down
sealing the creature on the other side
the other door didn't hold it what good
is that going to do researcher David
yelled more to the point Dr Carpenter
said turning and marching towards
Glennon he launched a furious punch at
the assistant knocking him to the floor
why did you set 914 to very fine clenin
the enraged doctor shouted you're the
one who Unleashed that Abomination you
maniac what Lennon replied fearfully
trembling I
already didn't
I'm sure of it you expect us to believe
that was a mistake gentlemen we need to
focus on the situation at hand the
security officer interjected regardless
of who's responsible we need to inform
the foundation higher-ups there's an
emergency lockdown Russell replied it
would have triggered the moment the
scp-610 specimen got free you've trapped
us with a monster clan in Dr Carpenter
spat hold on researcher David spoke up
wasn't it button's idea to use 914 in
the first place the common area fell
silent as everyone turned to look at Dr
botton did you plan for this doc David
push Von chuckled need I remind you my
friends that we all agreed to use the
Clockworks did we not all of our names
are on the request he answered besides
accusing me David that's rather Rich
coming from you what's that supposed to
mean the researcher fired back beckoning
his finger botan encouraged the rest of
the team to follow him across the common
area to where a row of lockers stood
each door bearing one of their names he
gestured to the one labeled David go on
button added shooting him a dirty look
David barch passed the disease expert
and opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leather-bound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying scp-610 the
researchers all knew a text on sarcasism
when they saw one it had been long known
that the flesh that hates was often
described in text revered by sarkic
Colts who worshiped death Decay and
disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarkist carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
research David protested I've never seen
that before it was in your locker the
doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh for your Twisted death
worshiping religion it certainly seems
that way button interjected after all
researcher David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even
you David pointed at the doctor you
planted this in my locker you're here a
sarkist clennan repeated in a nervous
stammer you made me turn the dial to
very fine you made that thing appear you
made me your accomplice anger tears
streamed on his face glennon's hand
reached for the security officer's gun
and went to draw it planning to shoot
David on the spot but as he went to pull
the weapon from the guard's holster it
wouldn't budge it was then that
assisting clenan stared in horror at his
hand his fingers had fused to the
guard's leg the officer gave a twisted
grin as his torso burst open tendrils of
Flesh latching onto clenin and
assimilating him just like it had done
before the flesh creature broke down its
victim's body making it a new part of
itself a grotesque mass of Limbs and
bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomach's turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell heard of voice whisper behind
him he turned to see Barton looking at
the scp-610 creature and smiling
researcher David was the closest and the
creature lunged at him pulling his leg
out from under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching his skin tearing
and Bones snapping as he became part of
it a new set of Limbs added to the
monster Dr Carpenter went to try and
pull him free but it was already too
late but he stepped back knowing that if
he touched it he would be infected too
the sound of running caught Russell's
attention and he spotted botton making a
break for it grabbing Dr Carpenter by
the sleeve the researcher pulled him in
the same direction partly running away
from the flesh as it assimilated David
and partly Chasing The sarkic Saboteur
the pair of them quickly caught up to
botton leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he wheezed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare upon us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but Bottom's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire ax for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the ax out of its case
while Spartan and carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lockdown Bond was saying they
need to let us out and then oh he let
out a blood curdling scream mid-sentence
as the ax blade wounded him Russell
pulled it back standing over the doctor
as he fell to the floor in agony Russell
have you lost your mind Carpenter
exclaimed no doctor he's the cultist I
have no idea how he tricked Glennon but
that flesh creature exists because of
him the researcher answered from the
floor unable to move thanks to his
injury Dr botton began to laugh it took
me years to infiltrate the foundation so
much time waiting to gain access to that
blessed flesh and now you've helped me
to refine it to create its ultimate
would fall you want to kill me go ahead
Russell my life doesn't matter for once
that creature is free it will bring
about a new age of Flesh and Grand
consist iron will reward me for the role
I played in unleashing it David was
right Carpenter realized button you
you've planted that book on him to throw
us off doctor we need to think of
something researcher Russell interjected
ax still in hand nobody knows more about
the flesh that hates than us there must
be a way to kill that thing otherwise if
it gets out of this lockdown it could
spread to everyone in the foundation
what about fire that's been effective
against 610 infectives before right yes
yes but the doctor desperately tried to
think this new being we've created she
created Russell argued looking at the
grimacing wounded button we cannot deny
the role we've all played in this
researcher Carpenter argued and we have
no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the flesh before its
refinement but we have to try sir the
researcher protested of course I agree
the sickening sound of a slithering
slick Mass was rapidly approaching still
laying on the floor in pain Dr botton
had been dragged to the middle of a
junction with Carpenter and Russell
hiding around either Corner suddenly
botton started hollering as the flesh
came into view practically calling it to
him oh look at you he exclaimed you're
better than I could have ever hoped for
looking down at him with the faces it
had collected the creature stabbed one
of its disgusting appendages through
botton drawing its body into its growing
form I am honored to give my life so
that the age of Flesh May begin the
doctor said weekly through the pain as
he was infected from around the corner
Carpenter had taken the sarkic text and
set its pages on fire with a cigarette
lighter turning to the creature he
hurled the massive burning paper at it
hoping it would be enough fire to spread
to the flesh while it was assimilating
bottom who they had left there as bait
the fiery book collided with the
monstrosity as Russell peeked around the
corner he saw the flesh retreating from
the Flames Bond's body now added to it
for a moment it seemed like the creature
was afraid of the fire but slowly it
drew nearer and nearer to the book with
ease it stamped down the Flames with
button's leg dowsing the fire and
suffering no damage to it at all
gripping the accent his hands Russell
went to charge the creature only to feel
something push him back Dr Carpenter had
stopped him run he yelled instantly
Russell turned and raced down the
corridor the sound of fleshy tentacles
whipping through the air he dared not
looked back just in case the monster was
right behind him eventually he reached
another corner and slammed his back
against it hand shuddering as he held
onto the fire ax he had no idea what had
happened to Carpenter maybe it got him
or perhaps he had managed to give it the
slip at the last second Russell came a
hush voice from around the corner one
the researcher recognized he turned to
see Dr Carpenter approaching him
sneaking like he was trying to avoid
being heard I think I managed to give it
the slip doctor whispered for a second
Russell backed up his hands tightening
around the ax handle this might have
looked like Dr Carpenter but was it are
you really you doctor he asked of course
I am Carpenter replied you don't think
that I'm not that monstrosity Russell
raised the ax defensively only to notice
the sadness and the doctor's face unable
to bring himself to swing even to find
out the researcher lowered his weapon
Carpenter looked grateful come on let's
get them to lift this lockdown he said
I'm sure an MTF can step in and take
care of our mistake as the pair of them
cautiously made their way towards one of
the locked doors Dr Carpenter reached
out a hand to place it on Russell's
shoulder
it was quiet too quiet that had been
what everyone remembered about that day
ask any member of personnel who was
working what the one thing they recalled
before it happened it all tell you the
same that it had been too quiet and Erie
lull and the foundation's usual
day-to-day activity followed by Untold
unspeakable chaos but the quiet had come
first and within that quiet a Madman was
hiding his name was Vince Barrett at
least that was his legal name but he
much preferred to go by his online
moniker of the tainted lizard or just
the zard for short anyone who chooses to
call themselves something like that in
an attempt to sound cool might well be a
person to avoid and in Vince sorry the
zard's case that sentiment was accurate
he was a social recluse devoting a lot
of his time to some of the darker
corners of the internet and we don't
just mean that he spent his days
trawling through Reddit no the zard's
interests were in the Paranormal the
unusual and inexplicable as well as the
community of his fellow internet
recluses dedicated to unearthing the
true Supernatural horrors of the world
eventually spending so much time in
corners of the online world where few
normal people would dare To Tread that
would lead to Zar becoming a member of
the prolific Forum known as parawatch
this was the real deal not just urban
legends and blurry photos of Bigfoot or
Faked handheld videos of people falling
into the back rooms parawatch had long
been known to and kept under the
surveillance of the SCP Foundation why
well because this Infamous online
Message Board would occasionally feature
posts about anomalies some even
including scps and leaked information
about the foundation themselves of
course hardly any of these posts stayed
up for very long before the foundation's
tech team scrubbed them permanently but
it was here on the parawatch Forum where
Vince Barrett would encounter a fateful
video clip acting fast he managed to
save the file before it was taken down
to his footage taken from the body cam
of a foundation security officer during
the midst of a containment breach the
zard hit play his hands shaking with
excitement the original poster of the
clip to parawatch had said that this
footage was perhaps the only known video
on the entire our internet that depicted
something known as
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile of
course those familiar with 682 and the
SCP Foundation will need no introduction
but Vince on the other hand had only
ever heard rumors about this creature
and now in the video playing on his
computer screen he was seeing it for the
first time the reptile was free from its
containment chamber tearing its way
through a foundation facility and making
quick work of dispatching the security
Personnel that dared to stand in its way
it was a force of unbridled Carnage and
rage destroying anything in its path and
adapting to its environment deep in the
periwatch Forum the zard had read rumors
and leaks from alleged x foundation
staff and detractors that 682 was like
something out of a nightmare they said
that the creature could adapt perfectly
in response to damage inflicted upon it
or to changes in its environment as well
as heal any injury it's a stained it
persisted it kept on going and something
about that enamored Vince to the
infamous anomaly he thought it was
beautiful the ultimate apex predator and
admired the hard to destroy reptile's
tenacity as well as its ferocity
watching the horrific Containment Breach
footage he realized then and there that
he was a devoted fanatic of scp-682 his
time on the dark side of the web had
twisted his mind and led him to make one
fateful decision that he needed to see
the creature in person that had been
almost a year earlier and in the time
since the tainted lizard had pulled on
every dark web string he knew of
eventually getting in contact with a
shady group called the chaos Insurgency
Vince had managed to get a hold of a
real-life SCP Foundation key card as
well as the location of the facility
they were holding 682 in and a forged
transfer document posing as a humble
unassuming janitor the zard had made his
way in inside the foundation and wasted
no time in making a beeline straight for
the acid tank where 682 was held he
stared at the creature through the glass
eyes wide and jaw slacked in utter awe
of the Monstrous reptile perhaps the
biggest fan of scp-682 on the planet
couldn't quite believe he was standing
in the presence of the creature itself
it barely seemed to pay him any mind
from the other side of the tank the acid
surrounding it melting 682 as fast as it
could heal seeing it in containment
enraged fence he hated that the
foundation had kept what he viewed as a
perfect organism locked up after having
tried time and time again to destroy it
don't worry the zard murmured
approaching the tank well over the
minimum safe distance you're a force of
unparalleled destruction and you don't
deserve to be here I'm gonna set you
free unfortunately after the glass had
been smashed and the alarm screamed out
that another Containment Breach was
occurring Vince would quickly find out
that the reptilian Beast he revered so
highly didn't quite hold him in the same
regard if you thought the zard was going
to make it all the way through the story
alive well then we regret to inform you
that you're sorely mistaken although not
as woefully misguided as Vince himself
who was the first person in the path of
scp-682 when he freed the creature with
all those leaks and rumors on pairwatch
had failed to mention about the heart to
destroy reptile was its vehement and
Relentless hatred for all other forms of
life including its very own fan and the
tainted lizard was only the first
casualty of
scp-682's latest Rampage but this time
was different sure 682 was easily
tearing its way through SCP Foundation
Personnel left and right security teams
were flung aside and ripped to shreds as
they tried in vain to recontain the
Monster research staff found themselves
tripping over each other trying to rush
out of the destructive path of the hard
to destroy reptile only to find
themselves the next to face its
ferocious attack in other words it
seemed to to mostly be another unbridled
Slaughter common fare for an scp-682
Containment Breach except rather than
Breaking its way out of the facility
this particular instance saw the
creature heading in the direction of
another anomaly
scp-914 better known as the Clockworks
now if a rampaging regenerative reptile
on the loose wasn't enough cause for
concern then seeing it moving along its
trajectory to another anomalous
refinement machine certainly was those
that had been on the other side of the
facility when the dearly departed zard
set 682 free we're now looking on in
horror as the hard to destroy reptile
burst into the room housing scp-914 the
foundation staff in the midst of panic
stared at security monitors with baited
breath palpable fear hanging in the air
each and every one of them knew that
scp-682 was more than just a Mindless
Beast the creature was fiercely
frighteningly intelligent sentient even
and as it approached the controls for
the Clockworks every onlooker secretly
hoped something or someone would step in
at the last second and prevent
scp-682 from entering the machine
unfortunately that's not what happened
scp-914 word into life its gears and
Gyro spinning as scp-682 entered the
input booth now normally the way the
Clockworks operates is by destroying any
item placed within it and replacing it
with something else in the output Booth
depending on its setting it either
completely disintegrates an item breaks
down an object into its base components
replaces it with an equivalent or
improves it and being set to very fine
as it was right now
scp-914 can even add anomalous
properties to whatever is put inside of
it but what happens when an
indestructible and infinitely adaptable
monstrosity is in the Clockworks while
it can't destroy and recreate a better
version of something that would be known
for being hard to destroying cannot the
entire machine was going haywire
scp-682 was adapting to the refinement
process refusing to let scp-914 unmake
it even to replace it with an improved
version of itself the hard to destroy
reptile and the Clockworks were at a
momentary stalemate and watched with
baited Breath by the foundation
scp-914 began to malfunction its
Clockwork components getting stuck as if
the machine was jammed its cogs were
clogged up unable to destroy the subject
in the input Booth the room around was
beginning to Shake in fact the very
ground was trembling at the force of the
whole machine shuddering enact the
abandoned all hope protocol the head of
research said desperately watching the
events unfold from the other side of the
building the site director looked at
them and nodded the pair of them
entering their secure passcodes to
activate this secretive security measure
just as they did a small earthquake
erupted underfoot the entire wing of the
facility housing the Clockworks and and
scp-682 had collapsed into the ground a
huge crater was all that remained
littered with wreckage of a whole
portion of the foundation site along
with broken pieces of scp-914 for the
next few minutes everyone was on edge
secretly hoping that scp-682 hadn't
survived maybe the Clockworks had
managed to destroy it but the sheer
force of doing so had caused the machine
to collapse in on itself or perhaps the
hard to destroy reptile was now buried
beneath several thousand tons of debris
dead at long last but the foundation
staff knew better than to get their
hopes up and sure enough just as an
armed security team approached the
crater something started stirring in the
rubble suddenly
scp-682 came bursting out of the crater
emerging in not quite the same state
although no less deadly than before the
Clockworks hadn't been able to unmake
the hard to destroy reptile but the
resultant malfunction and explosion had
imbued the creature with a whole host of
of new anomalous abilities it still
resembled its old self but was now more
humanoid standing by petal instead of on
all fours some of its body mass had
seemingly been reduced due to damage
sustained in the malfunction although
scp-682 was still plenty of feet taller
than an ordinary human being in fact it
could be any height it needed to be the
creature scaly skin seemed to be
shifting unnaturally moving of its own
accord like it was already preparing to
adapt to oncoming damage and as the
nearby security team were about to find
out this made it even deadlier than
before in a panic the foundation
officers opened fire only to find that
their weapons weren't operating the way
they should something caused excitation
of the copper shells of their bullets
making them either expand and block the
barrels of their guns or causing them to
backfire horribly injuring the security
Personnel wielding them before anybody
could even call an air support or heavy
artillery as a backup a number of the
foundation most powerful weapons
suffered even more catastrophic misfires
missiles detonated early they hadn't
even been aimed at scp-682 yet but they
would have been instead they exploded
taking with them a huge number of
foundation entities some miles away from
where the newly refined reptile now
stood
scp-682's regenerative Powers had been
altered by the Clockworks it wasn't
purely reactive to oncoming damage now
it was preemptive it could adapt to
attacks that hadn't even happened yet
with no way of stopping it
scp-682 began decimating everything in
its path with greater ferocity than ever
over the coming days the newly dubbed
impossible to destroy reptile began its
biggest Rampage yet entering a permanent
rage State and unleashing destruction on
a global scale it stormed through cities
and wiped out entire major population
centers in moments it seemed nothing on
Earth could stand against the refined
reptile fueled by by its singular
mission to wipe out all life in
existence the surviving Personnel of the
SCP Foundation soon came to learn that
no damage could be inflicted on the
creature whatsoever
scp-682 could predict attacks ahead of
the person that would carry it out and
then adapt changing the very world
around it so that attack never came the
impossible to destroy reptile's
adaptations usually took the form of
diverting any oncoming damage it
preempted it would take and instead
inflicted that same damage on whoever it
chose even though the machine had
malfunctioned the Clockworks had made
scp-682 that good at adapting to its
surroundings that the creature had
almost become a universal constant the
fact that it could not be harmed now
seemed to be as fundamental of a law as
that of gravity but that wasn't going to
stop the SCP Foundation from trying the
number of casualties the world over had
been increasing steadily day by day as
scp-682 continued its devastating
campaign of Slaughter some of the
remaining scraps of the foundation had
tried to subdue the creature but in the
attempts at fighting it with
Conventional Weapons were ill-advised to
say the least after all how do you fight
against a creature that can predict your
every move and counter them before
you've even thought of those moves well
you can try throwing something so
unexpected at it at least pulling
something out of left field means that
the chances of scp-682 seeing it coming
are slightly Slimmer and that was where
the abandoned all hope protocol came in
you see the foundation had been
anticipating that 682 Would One Day
become too powerful to contain long
before the creature had gained its new
ability to preemptively adapt and while
the worldwide death toll had climbed
from hundreds of thousands of innocent
people to the earliest Millions an
unlikely counter-attack was brewing one
so unexpected that even the impossible
to destroy reptile would struggle to see
it coming just as Humanity was facing
the brink of Extinction the foundation
dispatched their last hope at stopping
scp-682 other scps the abandon all hope
protocol had been devised for when the
suffering and destruction caused by
scp-682 became so great that there were
no other options left when it had been
activated Foundation agents stationed at
various sites across the world had
gathered a specially selected group of
anomalies each one was chosen because
they were known to be sympathetic
towards Humanity or at least be coerced
into taking on
scp-682 and now these scps were stepping
up to the plate ready to fight the
impossible to destroy reptile or more
likely to die trying
scp-076-2 the immortal Warrior known as
able was Infamous for picking fights the
ancient Sumerian swordsman had a
penchant for seeking out the most
challenging adversaries so convincing
him to take a crack at SCP 682 wasn't
all that difficult however rushing into
battle against the refined reptile Abel
quickly found he couldn't draw his
weapons from his pocket Dimension they
were dissipating the moment his fingers
touched them Vanishing faster than he
could draw no matter the warrior thought
he'd been alive for centuries and thus
had become a master in every form of
hand-to-hand combat as you can imagine
he didn't last very long left to slowly
revive inside his Stone tomb after
scp-682 had finished dispatching him
Abel's brother Kane incurred a slightly
different result when he went Toe to Toe
with the impossible to destroy reptile
scp-073 was hardly the fighter his
brother was but had the anomalous trait
of reflecting incoming damage back at
whoever was inflicting it on him so when
scp-682 attacked Kane theoretically the
same attack would have bounced back and
harmed the reptile itself and before
that's what would have happened but now
scp-682 could adapt preemptively a
strange never before seen phenomenon
occurred it appeared that neither
scp-073 nor the refined reptile were
harming each other at all however on a
metaphysical level the potential damage
of 682's attacks against Kane were being
reflected back towards the reptile only
for the creature to preemptively adapt
to the damage from its own attack being
inflicted back what resulted was a
feedback loop of Perpetual possible
damage that ended only when Kane
eventually passed out from shock
unfortunately while he could reflect
damage back at an attacker he felt the
pain of every hit and scp-682 had more
than just a mean right hook the
foundation had hoped given its 100
mortality record that scp-096 would have
no trouble killing the impossible to
destroy reptile or at the very least
harming it enough so that it could be
subdued after all 682 still needed to
see and anyone looking at the shotgun
quickly met their end but when the tall
pale humanoid approached scp-682
something unusual happened the reptile
could look at scp-096 able to see it
perfectly perhaps the creature's
adaptive properties were creating an
intentional blind spot in its Vision
removing scp-096 from view or maybe 682
no longer saw with just eyes perceiving
the world in a manner far beyond our
understanding of basic sight but
whatever the case the impossible to
destroy reptile made scp-096 turn and
flee in Terror compelled to put an end
to the reptile's reign of terror
scp-4494 the Specter manifested nearby
and tried to intervene the result was
nothing short of brutal a one-sided
fight that not even the living
embodiment of crime fighting could hope
to win after scp-682 had finished off
the Specter a strange black fluid began
oozing from nearby although one of the
hardest to Wrangle the foundation
believed believed that they had
convinced scp-106 to Aid in taking down
scp-682 the old man emerged from the
oily secretion shuffling menacingly
towards the impossible to destroy
reptile it seemed to freeze as if it was
taking a defensive stance against the
old man either that or tricking him into
getting closer before he could even
reach out a decrepit hand to touch the
reptile's shifting skin
scp-106 was suddenly coated in copious
amounts of the black substance he
secreted it coded him like thick tar the
more his decaying body produced the more
he was covered in it normally he was
resistant to the corrosive burning
effects of this substance however
scp-682's preemptive adaptation Powers
had caused scp-106 to overproduce the
oily substance enough to rapidly
dissolve the old man into a steaming
black puddle it was at this point that
scp-343 colloquially known as God
lowered his newspaper paper and looked
out of his window that is to say he
looked out of the huge hole that had
been left in the wall of his cell being
omniscient scp-343 was already burdened
with the awareness of what had happened
scp-682 had been refined into an even
worse version of itself by the
Clockworks up until now God had been
happy to avoid all the fighting and just
see how everything worked out but as
much as he tried to distract himself
scp-682 slaughtering other scps and
droves was getting in the way of his
reading oh this again in a split second
the entire universe had been unmade and
then remade Almost exactly the same
except scp-343 had made a slight
adjustment giving a little nudge to
cause and effect in a few places as a
result a certain misguided form user had
never and would never infiltrate the
foundation and break
scp-682 free leading to the hard to
destroy reptile being refined by the
Clockworks although while it had been
unceremoniously returned to its original
form and placed back in its acid tank
scp-682 could still remember the power
it had wielded only moments before
everything had been Rewritten all it
needed was another chance to get into
the Clockworks bodies all over the
ground next Twisted faces contorted in
Terror
SCP-173 not one but an army scatters out
through site 19 massacring researchers
one broken neck at a time pure chaos how
could this possibly have happened the
strobing of the blood red emergency
lighting was already fear-inducing
enough so it was being hidden under one
of the tables in the mess hall trembling
as the noise of alarms rang out through
the facility but the thing about the
flickering light scared SCP Foundation
researcher Mira Smithy all the more for
the few seconds of Darkness that came
between each flash of red if it had been
any other Containment Breach she
probably wouldn't have even noticed for
in those few seconds when the warning
light lit up only to cut out she
couldn't see a thing and her not being
able to see made it easier for them to
move around Mira had lost track of time
since the alarms had first sounded to
Mark the Containment Breach she tried to
keep count of the minutes of the
drumming of her heartbeat had thrown her
off there was no way of knowing if it
had been hours or only a few minutes
since everything went wrong of course
the SCP Foundation had plenty of
procedures and protocols in place to
prevent or respond to situations like
this yet the emergency alarms kept
echoing through the corridors lights
plunging the facility Into Darkness
every few seconds only to break it up
with a brief flash of red it seemed to
mirror from her hiding spot that this
breach had proven far too much for the
foundation's extensive procedures to
counteract maybe it was all over already
she thought after a few seconds or maybe
minutes under the table what if they had
gotten bored tired of slaughtering their
way through Foundation personnel and
slunk back to their containment chamber
that would have been simpler far less
terrifying than the alternative that
came creeping into Mira's head in the
form of her next thought what if she was
the only one left alive a last member of
sight Personnel still breathing just by
some random hundred to one chance and if
that was the case how long would it take
for them to find her how many even were
there a new sound just detectable below
the alarms broke through her Avalanche
of anxious questions
footsteps the noise of boots clomping
against the floor clearly belonging to a
human and not one of them cautious as to
which way her gaze was directed Mira
poked her head from out beneath the
table glancing around during the few
seconds where the red of the emergency
lights allowed her to see the steps were
getting closer and as they did
researcher Smithy realized some
something that made her fearful for her
fellow Survivor they were running away
and there was no way they could do that
while also looking back at what was
coming after them over here she hissed
in a hush tone at the sight of a pair of
legs crossing a nearby Corridor their
thick standard issue military boots
seemed to match those worn by the
foundation's security Personnel the
officer passed by only to stop and
tiptoe closer to the mess hall having
heard Mira's whispered call with the red
lights blinking it looked like every
other step the security officer took had
been edited out like they were
teleporting closer in the dark watching
intently from her Hiding Place reminded
Meera sickeningly of the things she was
hiding from how they moved and the
worrying fact that she couldn't see one
following the security officer hello
hello other man's voice as he entered
the mess hall under the table we were
whispered if we hide we can still see
them but they can't see us hiding he
replied no we need something I can
revert these things back to the original
it was so much easier to handle when
there was just one of them look let's
make a break for it I'm gonna grab
scp-3108 and get the lights back on if
we can restore visibility we might be
able to stand a fighting chance against
those
the officer was looking around the
cafeteria trying to locate the source of
researcher smithy's voice eyes
distracted then the intermittent
flickering of red light cut off again
plunging the entire mess hall into near
pitch Darkness at the same time there
was the sound of something heavy and
stone scraping against the flooring it
turned Mira's stomach and she
immediately covered her mouth she had no
idea if they could hear her breathing
could a creature of stone even detect
sound at all well the lights were down
and the security guard's back was turned
a pair of sculptures built from concrete
and rebar traces of spray paint over
their Stone skin appeared behind the
officer at impossible speed there was a
sickening crunch followed by the sound
of something dropping to the floor of
the mess hall as the emergency lights
flicked back on Mira could see them the
two copies of SCP-173 standing still
next to the table she was under bathed
in red light this nightmare had all
begun as an otherwise ordinary Friday
for the s CP Foundation only a few hours
earlier Mira had been brainstorming her
latest pitch for a series of experiments
involving scp-914 otherwise known as the
Clockworks scp-914 was a large machine
comprised of various cogs Gyros and
gears of Unknown Origin its function
however had long been documented and was
of great interest to the foundation any
object placed with an scp-914's input
Booth could be transformed destroyed or
improved depending on the clockwork's
setting rough would disintegrate the
subject chorus would dismantle it to its
base components and one to one would
merely replace the object with a similar
almost identical one then there were the
fine and very fine settings the former
would cause scp-914 to improve any item
and the later is capable of the same but
with one key difference very fine would
refine an object even more usually by
giving it anomalous properties the
foundation higher-ups had permitted
staff to freely conduct tests using the
Clockworks although approval was
required and all data was to be recorded
while many of the scientists at the
foundation were fixed on the mysterious
origin of scp-914 or the furthest extent
of its refinement capabilities Myra had
been thinking about it in a far more
practical way she wasn't interested in
the how or the why of scp-914's inner
workings nor who had built it her
experiments were born out of considering
better usages for the Clockworks it was
a machine that could provide endless
possibilities and Myra was determined to
make it to the fullest use of it in
order to solve actual real world
problems imagine for a moment she
announced reading off her cue cards as
she practiced pitching her experiment to
the foundation's senior researchers
imagine a world where nobody ever gets
sick where human beings are able to live
long healthy and prosperous lives maybe
dial back on the Star Trek her colleague
research assistant Jensen interchange
did really that's what you call
constructive criticism she retorted
before continuing if we apply the
transformative refinement powers of
scp-914 that world could be the future
that awaits us for example I'm proposing
tests that involve placing man-made
chemical compounds like painkillers
heart medication and other potentially
life-saving medicines through the
Clockworks refinement process I'm not
suggesting we need to set it to very
fine and create anomalous versions of
these things but what if even on the
fine setting we're able to improve the
effectiveness of our existing treatments
for all kinds of afflictions Jensen
raised their hand patiently waiting to
comment like a child in a classroom what
a few things they replied lowering their
hand first off some if not all man-made
medications include some kind of organic
component the o5 council have banned all
yes I'm fully aware of the containment
procedures Mira interrupted them that's
exactly why I'm trying to convince the
council or how just even Dr bright to
let let me step around I genuinely
believe we could be doing so much more
with scp-914 and I need them to see that
look I'm not here to rain on your parade
Smithy her assistant reassured I'm only
bringing up concerns that anyone will
have about this proposal you talked
about wanting to improve our existing
Medical Treatments which is Noble don't
get me wrong but have you considered the
wider effect that might have if you make
everyone on Earth more resistance or
even immune to everything then diseases
are going to evolve what if we end up
with a form of super bacteria resistant
to all forms of medication even if that
medicine's been refined in scp-914
trying to save the world might just
bring about its end I've thought about
that but if the council starts allowing
for biological testing again then the
solution is obvious we use the
Clockworks to eradicate whatever germs
or diseases are able to develop after
improving treatment options Myra
explained then adding besides that can't
be any more dangerous than what we've
been using scp-914 for I mean enhancing
other SCP that's a recipe for disaster
got to agree with you there Jensen's
side even without placing them in the
Clockworks the foundation's been way too
Cavalier with the Dangerous Ones
speaking of you know what tonight is
Smithy replied with a confused look date
night they stated elsewhere in the
facility a known to researcher Smithy at
that time one of the dangerous scps
Jensen had mentioned had been let out of
containment this was a regular
occurrence even if it was considered a
little unorthodox to some in fact the
only reason that the o5 council so often
turned a blind eye to it was because of
the researcher it involved Dr Alto cleff
it seemed clef had a certain fondness
for SCP-173 the sculpture a living
statue constructed from concrete and
rebar that could travel at impossible
speeds whenever it was unobserved most
Friday nights clef would have romantic
candlelit dinners with SCP-173 putting a
dress and blonde wig on the sculpture
and treating it like his beloved partner
the whole while watched by Dr clef and a
group of d-class acting as waiters and
Cooks
SCP-173 would stand motionless while the
bizarre date went on late into the night
it was no secret that the sculpture was
a highly aggressive creature with a
penchant for snapping the neck of the
nearest person the moment that they
blinked however it was only because of
Dr clef's reputation and track record
for the elimination of anomalies that he
was granted the special privilege of
whining and dining with SCP-173 this
time though partway through their
regularly scheduled date Dr cleff was
called away to deal with matters
relating to another anomaly he'd been
charged with decommissioning the pair of
d-class waiting on the doctor and his
date were instructed to wait keep a
close eye on SCP-173 alerting each other
in case they needed to Blink it was a
hell of a gamble a risk that could have
been avoided if the sculpture had been
transported back to its secure
containment chamber but Dr clef could be
persuasive that is to say he threatened
both d-class Waiters with the
bludgeoning from his ukulele if they
didn't do as he asked both the d-classes
stared directly at the sculpture each
one feeling the anxious beads of sweat
slowly crawling down their foreheads
worried that they'd both blink at the
same time by accident they announced
their need to refresh their eyes every
so often alternating between being The
Watcher and the one allowed to Blink all
the while as cp-173 was motionless
perhaps it was patiently waiting for Dr
clef to return or for one of the d-class
watching to slip up as if through some
cruel twist of fate a fly began to buzz
through the air drifting towards the
d-class with their eyes on SCP-173 it
looped and darted around its wings
making an annoying droning one of the
waiters announced he needed to Blink
again and the other told him he was free
to do so while he kept watch over the
sculpture at the exact same moment that
one man blinked the fly zipped its way
towards the second d-class distracting
him again and drawing his gaze for a
little more than a millisecond that fly
whizzing pass was the last thing he saw
as p173 darted forward it moved with
such incredible speed that it was
imperceptible grabbing the nearby
d-class the one who'd spotted the fly
and killing him instantly before the
other could even open his eyes when he
did SCP-173 had vanished from its spot
at the date night table nowhere to be
seen before the remaining d-class could
realize it was behind him
SCP-173 had made short work of its other
Observer it began zipping unseen through
the corridors of the SCP Foundation
facility Dr clef had returned to his
date only to find the two d-class
waiters dead and SCP-173 missing
immediately he had raised the alarm
meaning that research staff were too
busy fleeing to safely pay any attention
to the sculpture quickly making its way
through the site swept up in the
evacuation Half deafened by the alarms
in all the commotion researcher Myra
Smithy hadn't even realized she left the
door to the Clockworks wide open
shuffling down a corridor with her
fellow researchers the light suddenly
went out a few nearby screamed in panic
at having been unceremoniously thrust
into the dark Myra blindly reached for
Jensen's hand only to hear the sounds of
multiple heavy concrete feet dragging
along the floor suddenly the emergency
lights blinked she turned and to her
horror she saw SCP-173 with its Stony
arms around Jensen's neck their face
stricken with sheer Terror Tears in
their eyes but now Myra quickly realized
as the corridor was filled with shrieks
of fear from the other researchers that
there was more than one sculpture now
Myra barely managed to escape with her
life and all the confusion crawling out
of the low-lit corridor on her hands and
knees while the multiple new SCP-173
instances slaughtered anyone that
couldn't see them since then she had
been hiding hearing the scraping steps
of the sculptures traveling around the
facility unobserved they had attacked
the fuse boxes first as if in a
calculated tactical move take out the
lights and suddenly everyone found it
much harder to see them even through the
fear it was hard for Mira not to blame
herself for all the chaos she couldn't
remember whether she'd left the door to
scp-914 open or not but it hadn't taken
her long to figure out that the
Clockworks had something to do with this
madness somehow SCP-173 had made its way
there had been able to operate the
Machinery while the foundation staff
were distracted by their own evacuation
presumably with scp-914 set to very fine
the sculpture had been transformed into
its ultimate refined form or multiple
forms it seemed there was a veritable
horde of scp-173s running amok through
the facility it made sense Myra reasoned
in some Twisted cruel anomalous way the
sculpture had only ever been a danger
when unobserved the second anyone took
their eyes off of it so much has blinked
it would strike how does a machine like
scp-914 improve upon that easy it gives
the sculpture the power to replicate
itself anyone can can look at multiple
things at once of course but nobody can
look at everything simultaneously even
if someone was watching a pair or three
scp-173s one more could easily slip up
behind them for the kill still hidden
under the table Myra's eyes were locked
on the pair of sculptures in the mess
hall the body of the security officer
out of focus in her peripheral vision
she dared not look away Frozen in sheer
fear that the second she blinked they
would lift up the table and find her she
had been so overwhelmed so paralyzed
with her Terror that she had forgotten
about the lines as the emergency
lighting flickered again the sculptures
both moved shifting across the mess hall
as the room went dark only to stop and
place the second Myra could see them
again they hadn't gotten closer in fact
both looked to be leaving the only thing
keeping them here was her she was
watching them and it had Frozen them in
place their greatest strength the
imperceptible movement and speed of
SCP-173 was offset by an indisputable
weakness of their anomalous biology they
couldn't stop someone from looking at
them and couldn't stop themselves
becoming still solid concrete when they
were being watched mulling over her
options Myra decided to follow through
with the plan from the Fallen security
guard to retrieve
scp-3108 and try to undo what the
Clockworks had done slowly she slipped
out from under the table keeping both
eyes on the pair of sculptures keeping
them lashed to one spot as she gradually
backed out of the mess hall the lights
went out and plunged the area Into
Darkness again and researcher Smithy
could hear the heavy concrete scraping
of the two sculptures looking for her as
she blindly made her way through the
facility she managed to evade the
roaming Stone creatures resisting her
natural instinct to hide and looking
directly at any she encountered on the
way making sure to stay out of their
view if she saw them she'd freeze them
if they saw her they'd chase her
eventually fishing
scp-3108 out of a containment box Myra
held the weapon in her hand it was a
heavily modified Nerf gun which she
loaded a foam dart into and pulled the
plastic slide back the creatively named
nerfing gun had almost the opposite
effect of scp-914 instead of improving
Something
scp-310a Turned whatever was shot with
it into an inferior equivalent object
something worse than itself it just
might work drawing the gun as she heard
the sound of scraping concrete getting
nearer and nearer Myra turned the corner
coming face to face with one of the
sculptures she held the gun High closing
the gap between them making sure she
didn't miss but wary she needed to fire
before the lights blinked off again she
squeezed the plastic trigger sending the
foam darts shooting out of the barrel of
the nerfing gun the flimsy projectile
collided with the SCP-173 instance
bouncing off its head and landing on the
floor for a split second the light
dimmed again then came back on Myra's
heart had lurched in her chest only to
see that this sculpture hadn't moved at
all she leaned closer to it blinking
intentionally it still didn't move it
was rooted to the ground fixed just a
statue rendered powerless by the nerfing
gun excitedly Myra knelt down and
scrabbled on the floor to retrieve the
dart just as the emergency lighting
flickered out again in her excitement
Myra was too focused on reloading
scp-3108 that is until she heard the
shuffling of concrete and rebar behind
her the lights were still out and she
fumbled blindly for the foam dart as the
noise got closer and closer her
fingertips brushed the projectile
knocking it further away when suddenly
the lights came back up but as she
reached for it researcher Smithy felt a
large cold presence behind her something
huge and heavy and made of stone and
lingering at the very corner of her eye
before she could turn around and face it
something grabbed Myra and a sickening
snap rang out through the corridor
Fearless Relentless and one of the most
utterly brutal Warriors to ever walk the
face of the Earth with a body count
somewhere in the high hundred thousands
if not well into multiple Millions given
just how long he's been around for many
of you will already be well aware of
scp-076-2 also known as able on the
surface he's a man of Middle Eastern
descent covered in tattoos of occult
symbols and demonic faces usually
contained within a stone Cube designated
as
scp-076-1 Abel will often emerge in a
homicidal State killing anyone and
anything directly around him how well by
any means available to him but primarily
by pulling a wide array of bladed
weapons seemingly out of thin air this
is thanks to a tiny pocket Dimension
that only he can reach into which is
also always stocked with an assortment
of deadly implements for his latest
murder spray as if being highly combat
proficient and always armed didn't make
him enough of an imposing threat scp-076
II also possesses a near superhuman
resistance to damage making him
incredibly difficult to take down and
even if someone is able to eventually
neutralize him Abel will also come back
resurrecting inside
scp-076-1 to fight another day what you
may not know is for a Time Abel actually
worked alongside the SCP Foundation
although nowadays they prefer to keep
him locked away in a secure containment
facility underwater which they will
flood with seawater if he ever escapes
but Abel was once appointed the leader
of his own mobile task force
omega-7 referred to under the code name
of Pandora's Box you see the foundation
realized that
scp-076-2 held an especially high regard
for those who proved well able to best
him in combat and it was this strange
code of honor that Abel held that the
foundation hoped to exploit with the
creation of Pandora's Box comprised of
MTF operatives that had earned Abel's
respect most by previously beating him
in a fair fight or as Fair as a fight
with a man who can summon swords through
a tear in the fabric of reality can be
these agents would support Abel during
missions in the field during which the
SCP Foundation were able to deploy the
anomalous warrior in various tactical
engagements however this didn't last
long eventually Abel grew tired of
carrying out the orders of the
foundation The Immortal Warrior craved a
challenge Breaking Free of containment
and turning on the foundation resulting
in able being neutralized by an on-site
nuclear weapon this marked the end of
the fragile alliance between
scp-076-2 and the SCP Foundation leaving
the existence of omega-7 a classified
secret and one of the organization's
most embarrassing missteps well but what
if that hadn't happened what I felt
there in the infinite Multiverse there
was a world where Abel had been allowed
to remain a part of omega-7 and the
mobile task force was never disbanded
well you're about to find out in our
world Abel's dissatisfaction with being
a member of Pandora's Box first became
apparent when he began putting the rest
of his unit through live fire exercises
brutalizing his men despite these
exercises being intended as for training
purposes only but in this world the
injuries and even casualties able
inflicted on the rest of omega-7 were
met with a much different response the
o5 Council of this alternate version of
the SCP Foundation viewed Abel's
outbursts during training as acceptable
losses every time he would injure one of
omega-7 the council would demand that
Replacements be on hand to become part
of the task force drawn from the ranks
of the other mtfs at their disposal
after all Abel was a valuable asset for
carrying out the foundation's Dirty Work
by continually replenishing his team
with reserves from their seemingly
inexhaustible supply of other MTF agents
the o5 Council of this world were able
to keep
scp-076-2 firmly under their employee
however it is also important to note
that Abel's patience for these new
recruits was far more limited than the
original
omega-7s those men had all been
hand-picked by Abel personally and
appointed to the project given that he
had some modicum of respect for them as
combatants whereas all of their
Replacements were plucked at random from
the foundation's other mtfs as a result
scp-076-2 would carelessly kill or wound
more and more of these reserves during
combat missions hardly distinguishing
between friend and foe but despite this
the o5 council refused to discontinue
the omega-7 project viewing these as
acceptable losses and letting the
success rate of Abel's missions justify
the depletion of their other mobile task
forces under Abel's leadership and the
command of the o5 council Omega 7 would
become the foundation's primary rapid
response unit and the most deployed task
force for Dangerous field operations and
working for the foundation meant that
every field mission was a highly
dangerous one such was the case during
one Containment Breach where scp-682
managed to get free of its acid tank a
rampaging infinitely adaptable hard to
destroy reptile on the loose
slaughtering all in its path was bad
enough but the o5 council had received
Intel that there was something more
behind this breakout than it first
seemed and so able and the rest of his
latest Omega 17 were sent in to pacify
scp-682 bursting into the facility eager
to once again be freed from containment
and the monotonous underwhelming
experience of training able flew into
combat drawing black swords from his
personal Armory he began to tear through
everything and everyone in his path
unfortunately for the foundation
Personnel on site this also meant that
they were subject to Abel's Relentless
wrath as if running away from scp-682
wasn't that enough fleeing research
staff were quickly met with the swing of
scp-076-2's weapons and removed from the
premises in a brutal fashion still this
meant little to Abel and even less to
the o5 council as far as they were
concerned even their own staff were just
collateral damage more acceptable losses
justified by Abel's perfect record for
successful high-risk High reward field
missions however that perfect record was
about to be tarnished for good you see
this Containment Breach wasn't your
average
scp-682 escape attempt it was instead a
situation that had been meticulously
planned and carried out for one purpose
this breach was intended specifically to
draw Abel out since he had become the
SCP foundation's primary weapon in
response to danger in the field a
particularly devious third party had
begun to take note the chaos Insurgency
a splinter faction that began its life
as an off the books Black Ops unit for
the foundation themselves had been
monitoring Abel's deployment by the o5
council in this universe their origin
was the same as an ours and the
Insurgency took a certain disdain to
seeing an anomalous individual carrying
out the kind of operations their group
had been formed to undertake for the
foundation additionally the use of
scp-076-2 as a personal attack dog by
the o5 council is hypocrisy the
Insurgency believed in the practical
application of anomalies rather than
mocking them up and keeping them
contained and it was for this belief
that they had been vilified by the
foundation and yet here was the same
organization sending Abel on missions
with no care for the harm he caused and
so as a result the chaos Insurgency had
conducted an operation to break into the
foundation free
scp-682 and send the hard to destroy
reptile on a rampage also they could
take their shot at April being ambushed
by a group of cows Insurgency operatives
on his way to engage
scp-682 Abel was admittedly caught by
surprise but by now his combat prowess
was second to almost nobody else in the
world the insurgents dog piled on April
unleashing every ounce of Firepower they
had brought to bear on the immortal
Warrior the ensuing firefight destroyed
an entire wing of the foundation
facilities explosive weapons being
detonated in the hopes that the
Insurgency could subdue Abel all the
while
scp-076-2 Shrugged off the oncoming
damage catching rockets that were
launched at him and throwing them back
in the direction of the chaos insurgents
it was a bloodbath nearly the entire
Omega 17 that had accompanied Abel and
provided him with fire support were
lying dead the same could also be said
for the insurgency's forces too though
with each of them being gradually felled
by The Warriors Mini Weapons but by this
point Abel was approaching exhaustion
and there was still one more enemy left
standing it had been unfurling
destruction all on its own angrily
devouring the few Foundation Personnel
that were left and now the scaly form of
scp-682 came lumbering around the corner
the battle was brutal in this universe
Abel and the hard to destroy reptile had
never crossed paths before but scp-682
could smell the difference in Abel's
physiology his innate ability to resist
damage and resurrect time and time again
the creature already held the stain for
anything and everything living and so
presented with a man who technically
couldn't stop living
scp-682 entered an Unstoppable rage
State taking the exhausted able down
with ease but losing in the grudge match
against
scp-682 wasn't quite as bad as things
were about to get for Abel Reviving
inside of his Stone sarcophagus the
ancient warrior was confused the
foundation were letting mount it had
been a long time years even since he had
last died even temporarily over the
course of all of his omega-7 missions he
hadn't needed to reappear back inside
scp-076-1 for quite a considerable while
and now that he had a very large seed of
Doubt had been sown the o5 council were
Furious just as angry at
scp-076-2's apparent failure as Abel was
the perfect operational track record of
their top anomalous asset was now
tarnished the question started to spread
through the council members if their
sword Wheeling virtually invulnerable
secret weapon wasn't as effective as
they had previously thought then what
was the use of continuing to deploy able
and so began a debate within the o5
council upon what was to be the fate of
scp-076-2 in this universe he had served
the foundation well but a weapon that is
only effective even ninety percent of
the time still leaves a margin of error
it was that risk that potential for
Amber knowing that Abel wouldn't always
succeed in his missions that caused the
o5 council to reconsider his
applications as a field operative there
were some in the council who argued that
this was a highly specific isolated
incident the chaos Insurgency had
specifically engineered the scp-682
Escape as a way to draw Abel out after
all just because he failed this time did
not indicate a pattern of failure but
this argument was eventually shot down
especially when the foundation's Ethics
Committee decided to throw in their two
cents they demanded able status as a
field agent be revoked and levied for
the immediate disbanding for the omega-7
project pulling replacements for that
task force from other mtfs at the
foundation had left them with a
significantly depleted reserve of troops
and then came the argument about just
how acceptable the losses were when Abel
was left loose a decision was ultimately
made to for at least the moment rescind
scp-076-2's field operative privileges
and suspend any further development of
or recruitment into omega-7 however
there was one crucial factor that nobody
on the council had taken into
consideration when they made their
verdict and that was how badly Abel
would react to the news as you may have
already predicted Abel was Furious to
hear he would be held in containment
until further notice his anger stemmed
not from his defeat at the jaws of
scp-682 but at how quick the foundation
seemingly was to question his combat
prowess he lost one battle out of
hundreds thousands even and all of a
sudden the o5 council were going to lock
him away all because of one defeat you
dare Abel bellowed when he was given the
news I Am The Greatest Warrior on this
planet and have been made a pond by your
foundation I give you my strength my
skill and the moment I falter you'll
turn your back on me you damn you dare I
will show you what real power looks like
overcome with rage it didn't take long
for Abel to force his way out of
containment he'd been active as a field
agent within the foundation for so long
now that he had long since figured out a
way to escape his underwater prison
before the emergency containment
measures had a chance to stop him as he
broke free he made sure to take down
plenty of security staff along along the
way and to make matters worse he didn't
stop there before long Abel was on a
Warpath against the SCP Foundation every
few days reports would come in of a
massacre at a foundation facility
security footage recovered from the
wreckage after each incident would show
Abel arriving Prime for battle a sword
in each Hand by the time he left after
his brutal remorseless attack he'd be
drenched in the blood of the entire
site's Personnel the foundation had
little in its once huge Arsenal to fight
back with given the number of MTF agents
reassigned to omega-7 their forces were
far more limited if not almost depleted
they dispatched attachments to clean up
the wake of Abel's destruction but not
one Squad sent after the anomalous
Warrior came back alive part of the
problem was the foundation couldn't
predict where Abel would show up next or
which of their sights he knew about and
was planning to hit from their
perspective his attacks were spontaneous
the result of Rage at the foundation but
without any premeditated plan in mind
and that was exactly what Abel wanted
them to think by seeming to attack at
random he was therefore able to cover
the true intention behind each
engagement he was looking for something
during his considerable time leading
omega-7 he had heard about a machine
that could improve anything placed
inside of it
scp-914 better known as the Clockworks
and before long Abel found what he was
looking for by the time the foundation
realized what the Unstoppable Warrior's
plan was it was already too late Abel
was storming into the facility that
housed scp-914 with no intention of
leaving until he'd used it the
foundation had banned testing of
biological matter within the Clockworks
but Abel wasn't beholden to their rules
anymore in fact he barely was when he'd
worked with them before cutting down
guards and researchers survivors fleeing
in Terror Abel stepped up towards the
massive gears and cogs the Clockwork
components that made up scp-914 he
wasted no time setting the machine to
very fine with this setting the
Clockworks would take whatever was in
the input booth and improve it usually
by giving it anomalous Properties or in
the case of Able by giving him further
anomalous properties stepping inside the
were of Machinery drowned out the
emergency alarms as Abel reached his
goal to become the ultimate warrior the
embodiment of the very concept itself
racing to the scene a chopper cleared
the smoke as it approached under an
emergency executive order from the o5
council The View surviving remnants of
the foundation's mobile task forces had
been combined into a singular Strike
Team there were not many left
considering how many others from their
units had been previously siphoned into
omega-7 only to die as collateral damage
in the team's missions with Abel
remember scp-00
field commander parked while the MTF
Strike Team held their guns nervously
aboard the aircraft primary objective is
to neutralize him by any means reports
indicate that he may be trying to access
scp-914 so be advised An Almighty
explosion boomed through the Airborne
vehicle engulfing the cockpit in Flames
beta
the commander radioed to Foundation
command ever everyone raise yourselves
for impact the helicopters spiraled out
of the air crashing to the ground in a
Twisted hunk of metal the surviving
members of the Strike Team scrambled out
of the wreckage hauling the more badly
wounded out of the ruined aircraft
contact someone yelled in horror enemy
contact behind us
the remaining Foundation foot soldiers
turned and Drew their weapons opening
fire on something suspended a few feet
in the air above them a hail of gunfire
rang out as the team opened fire the
second they saw who it was it was able
and he was flying floating above them
his hair whipped in the wind the
oncoming storm of bullets seemed to
Ricochet off his skin in actuality they
weren't even hitting him melting away
before they could make contact they
might as well have been firing pea
shooters for how little effect their
guns had the barrage only stopped when
one of the Strike Team launched a
short-range rocket at the newly refined
Warrior it detonated but when the smoke
from the blast cleared Abel was still
hovering in the air without so much as a
scratch my turn he announced reaching
into his pocket Dimension Abel pulled
something out not a weapon not yet
instead it was a formless dark shadowy
mass that moved like liquid metal
reacting to the movement of his hand as
he drew the substance out it formed
seemingly at Abel's command and it
wasn't just swords he could create now
drawing on his experiences from his
omega-7 missions any weapon that Abel
had previously seen or could think of he
now had at his disposal the Strike Team
looked up in horror as a veritable swarm
of black non-reflective constructs
hovered in the air on either side of
Abel each one in the shape of a rocket
flinging both arms towards the
foundation troops Abel sent his New
Creations raining down on them the
Strike Team turned heel and fled for
their lives although none of them got
very far Abel's Rockets engulfed the
area around them in a volley of
explosions leaving not a single thing
standing he had just effortlessly built
an airstrike from virtually thin air and
thrown it at the foundation's last
remaining MTF agents and he wasn't done
there with his Newfound Powers Abel's
Campaign Of Destruction swept the entire
world in a last Act of desperation the
SCP Foundation offered freedom to any
anomaly that permanently took down
scp-076-2 they all flooded out of
containment to take their shot the
plague doctor the shy guy the Specter
but they barely slowed Abel down his new
constructs were devastating weapons
taking the form of not just blades but
projectiles of every size and shape all
of them lethal before long Abel had Lane
waste to the entire Foundation but still
he wanted more scp-914 hadn't just
improved Abel's existing anomalous
powers and granted him the ability to
fly at supersonic speeds in doing so it
had Amplified his range too he loathed
the human race and sought to absolutely
decimate every single living thing no
one could best him in combat now and in
his mind Twisted by anger not one of
them was worthy of his respect he tore
planes apart with his bare hands smashed
tanks to pieces and leveled entire
cities with his unlimited weapons it
took a few years maybe a decade at the
most but by the end of it Abel sat atop
a pile of billions upon billions of
bones with his refined abilities he had
done something Unthinkable committed
omnicide he had killed everyone in the
world of course this was indeed another
world one different to ours luckily here
our version of Abel is still locked up
underwater but somewhere out there there
is an Abel who is watching the sun
rising over an entirely dead World his
world want to own an SCP of your own go
to scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now to see the result of
more anomalous experiments with the
Clockworks go and check out what if
scp-0 96 was put inside scp-914 and
scp-914 what did you put in it for more
Clockworks related stories